open up the environment and agriculture
house committee this morning and we have
a special presentation from
the
i lost my notes
there we are that's way at the top the
exotic aquatic weed and animal species
committee so i'm going to turn it over
to them for a presentation and uh my
understanding is we'll have a 15 or 20
minute presentation some time for
questions is that correct
yes mr chair all right well thank you so
uh representative suzanne smith is going
to lead us in the presentation thank you
welcome to the e a thank you good to be
here again um i just wanted to say that
the aquatic invasive weeds and species
committee
is a permanent committee that was formed
quite a while ago 20 years ago and
originally it was pretty much milfoil
that people talked about but now there
is a lot more happening and i'm joined
today by michelle davis michelle davis
from new hampshire lakes and also amy
smagula from des who is our
biggest expert in the state in my mind
on aquatic invasives well welcome to all
of you look forward to your presentation
great
so basically the agenda for today is
we're going to talk about um what is
what is the threat of aquatic invasives
and what are things that are being done
now
for those
and then what is the future outlook are
we doing enough and more what more can
we do
and a death the definition of invasive
species and this is all on the um
presentation so i'm kind of just i'm the
what he called the vocal on the
presentation
and they're non-native to the ecosystem
and the introduction causes or is likely
to cause economic or environmental harm
or harm to human health
and a lot of a lot of invasives come
into this country um in the ballast of
large ships
and then they spread out across the
country
um this is a map which is not super easy
to see and it but mostly what you can
see all those dots all the different
colored dots are different invasives in
different parts of the state and as you
can see um there is a lot in the lakes
region along in the southern part of the
state and even over to the seacoast and
really almost nothing up in the northern
tier of the state as far as invasives go
which is nice
but it has to do with the population and
how many people are going in and out
with boats
and we have a number of infested water
bodies in new hampshire
and even though you'll see milfoil is in
water bodies and maybe
brittle niad is in only a few but there
can be two or three different species in
one
uh water body
does that sound right michelle yeah
so the most threatening there are quite
a few that are the most threatening ais
to new hampshire and the first is
milfoil which is i stated in the
beginning is
is the most prolific in this state and
this is asquam marina at on squam lake
and you can see there's a reflection of
trees but if you look under the water
there is like solid plant life and that
is the milfoil that had taken over that
area
and this is not a new picture
so another um
invasive species is the fan wart
and that is newer than milfoil it wasn't
here probably 20 years ago i don't think
and then we have the water chestnut
that's the nashua river which was pretty
much covered with water chestnut and i
believe that has mostly been taken care
of yes
that has been eradicated at this point
and then we've also got the brittle niad
european brittle naiad the reason it's
called brittle naiad is because little
tiny pieces break off easily
and then start the spread of the
uh invasive wherever it lands
it also gets caught in like propellers
or you know it easily grabs on to other
boats and stuff and then we have in the
animal section we you know this
committee deals with
uh aquatic invasive animal species but
we're not talking about fish we usually
are just focusing on the non-vertebrates
the invertebrates the the muscles um
zebra mussel which we don't have
actually very much of if any in new
hampshire and then asian clams this is
the bottom of the merrimack river in
beau it's totally
infested with these asian clams
i'm going to turn it over to michelle
for a bit
so
not only are our
invasive species unsightly and
unpleasant they can have really
significant
impacts on
recreation tourism and boating
i'm not sure if you all have seen it but
recently
dartmouth college released a study that
that valued lake winnipesaukee at 17
billion dollars um 300 million of that
is tourism revenue 110 million of that
approximately is boating and fishing
revenue and 42 million of that is summer
camp revenues so all of those industries
could significantly be impacted by
aquatic
invasive species
and
to my understanding lake sunapee is is
being studied next and so
we'll have
and those are just two of our thousand
lakes here in new hampshire
um
and
so and then as far as you know other
other economic impacts property taxes
infestations can reduce property values
by 10 to 20 percent
you can imagine not wanting to buy a
property
if
off your dock looks like that and you
can't swim and your boat propeller gets
caught every time you try to
try to leave
that study indicated that property
values on winnipesaukee
are worth over 16 billion dollars so a
10 to 20 percent decrease in that
property value on winnipesaki alone
would be
devastating
and then you know so the outdoor
recreation industry in new hampshire is
2.6
of
the state gdp um the last statistic i
saw and that's not just boating and
fishing but the last statistic i saw
it's 26 000 jobs and 1.1 billion dollars
in wages annually
so
if new hampshire continues to have
aquatic invasive species spread and we
gain a reputation for being somewhere
that's unpleasant to recreate
you can see that that could have pretty
significant impacts on our on our
economy
these are some photos of
zebra mussels
and and other crustaceans and their
impacts the great lakes are are
struggling significantly with these
issues
and so thinking about
infrastructure impacts there's dam
intake tower covered in in crustaceans
and so
we're we already have
infrastructure issues to be dealing with
here in new hampshire and then to add
zebra mussels or something like that on
top of it
could be really devastating
so the
new hampshire has a whole plan of how we
can deal with the threat of the aquatic
invasives and it starts with prevention
which of course is the least expensive
in most instances for any problem we
have prevention is the best medicine
then we have early detection so the you
know if you see a piece of milfoil
growing in your
neighborhood
in your local lake and there has never
been any before and you report it it can
usually be taken care of fairly easily
and then rapid response is the next key
thing you know if you respond quickly
you can deal with these problems more
easily
and then there is treatment and control
which the price goes up on that and then
uh and that can encompass a lot of
questions
here and then long-term management is
the most expensive and that is like over
the years a a community a lake
association dealing with
that and so prevention and early
detection
michelle
so
the new hampshire lakes
facilitates the lake host program that
you may be familiar with
people in blue shirts at boat launches
um
who are checking boats that are entering
and leaving water bodies for aquatic
invasive species
we've been the the program's been in in
existence for 20 years
this year
we're anticipating about 80 groups
um with
700 paid and volunteer lake hosts
we're covering 80 ram 80 lakes and 100
ramps and last year we conducted
about 80 000 inspections and of those 80
000 inspections 15 of them
um were resulted in saves which is
specimens prevented from entering a
water body
and several of which
several of which of those saves were on
uninfested currently uninfested water
bodies
so
and then weed watchers and river runners
are those those early detection
volunteers they monitor lakes and ponds
for ais and so people are are
paddling the the
the shallow areas of the lakes that you
can see the bottom to to monitor for um
suspicious specimens and then they're
they're taking samples of those and
bringing them to des for identification
um and then on the legislative side of
things um it's uh under current state
law any boat used in
new hampshire should have been cleaned
and drained before arriving at the next
water body and there's rules against
transporting any exotic plants
to or from new hampshire waters there is
also since 2019 we've had a best
available tech law that says that
boaters must use the best technology
available to them
as long as it's free and available when
they're
entering or leaving a water body
so that best tech can look like a number
of different things it could be a garden
hose it could be
some tongs to remove
specimens or it can be as robust as that
the cd3 unit that you see there in the
center it's new hampshire lakes has a
mobile solar powered
waterless
boat cleaning station there's a vacuum
there's pressurized air to help dry the
boat
and then there's some brushes and um
and
the the technical term for them is reach
grabbers but they're giant tongs that
you can pull specimens off your boat
with
and so the goal of that program
ultimately is to
inspire and encourage
communities to install permanent
fixtures the cd3 units come in a number
of different sizes and
and levels of technology but
so we're working on our deployment plan
for this year but we're partnering with
marinas and state agencies as well as
local lake associations and and towns
to um just
increase the awareness and education of
this program
so the rat when we get into the rapid
response and treatment and control
we have
the
different lake associations will work
with des and there will be divers that
dive down and there is a diver assisted
suction
diver assisted suction
program and i know that i we went on a
field trip a few years ago and at squam
lake and there was a boat and we were
all on the boat and under us were divers
and they had like a vacuum thing
and they would like find the invasives
pull them up by the root put them in the
vacuum and then they would come up on
the boat and then get sorted so if
anything got on there that wasn't an
invasive like a crawfish or something
like that they could throw it back in
the water but any of the invasives that
were coming up were then out of the
water system so that's a way because a
lot of times just uh
you're in water that's a little deeper
than you want to be in and if it's a
large infestation that can be very
helpful
it's hand pulling and then diver
assisted uh that there's also something
called a benthic barrier which is
something that if you have a lake level
that it's uh the lake level is lowered
in the fall
and so you put this barrier down
and then leave it there so then the next
year nothing can grow there
and that is sometimes effective and then
the last course of action would be
herbicide application and that is done
under the supervision of des and
department of agriculture which
regulates herbicides and pesticides
unfortunately matt dosiack who's our
member on the
aquatic invasives committee couldn't be
here today but i'm sure that amy smagula
could answer any questions about the
herbicides which i know is under the
purview of this committee
and then long-term management
this is a huge program
for
areas and lakes and small lakes that are
impacted and they a lot of them will
have a lake association for their small
lake or
whatever and then
they will work with des
to try to mitigate what they can do
to problem solve and
uh
lessen the invasives in their water body
and the uh we were the
on on the invasives
aquatic invasive species committee
des is represented and des does a large
part of the work here
with the
with aquatic invasives
and their the
program which provides grants to
municipalities and also
pays for
some of the remediation things that are
happening
is paid funded by boat registration fees
and recently the general fund and then
we have a new decal which will raise
money for this program also
and then as i said department of
agriculture markets and food division of
pesticide control
manages for herbicide treatments
and they uh matt is like works part time
doing this as part of his
job there
and then the fish and game department
fishing it's interesting because
although des handles aquatic invasive
plants fish and game is responsible for
animals which has to do with spiny water
flea
and the asian clam and any other
invertebrates
and so they are represented director
mason is on the committee on this
committee
and
they we are working all together trying
to better coordinate this animal species
was only added to the committee in the
last 10 years
so this has been
an interesting uh transition and we're
all learning a lot
and the committee was established in
and as i said this so
we educate legislators because next year
we may come to you for money or next
year we may come to you for a new plan
or editing so it's nice to uh educate
people to the situation and so many of
us live near a lake or visit our lakes
and ponds and rivers
so
we
we do a lot of work we meet once a month
and then here's a explanation of the
funding and how this is grown from boat
registration
and interesting you know some people
might say
we have an annual registration of 92
over 90 000 boats every year that are
registered in new hampshire and some
people may say why do we keep raising
the boat registrations but when we work
with marine trades and other
organizations they're like happy to have
the increase in registration fees rather
than any other
change in
monies that are
asked for and that's something that they
have supported over the years
and other funding uh as i said about
i don't know
was it yeah 2019 uh 400 000 over two
years was allocated for the aquatic
invasive species
work
and then we have the decals
that just was started and that is just
being implemented last year was the
first year
and then there are private donations and
municipal funds
and a lot of that is when for small lake
associations
like squam lake association the sunrise
lake association and they work with des
and then the people
pay some of the money too
and here's expenditures just to give you
a quick thing if you can see it the
purple is what this the grants that the
state gives to the different
municipalities and lakes
and then the local contributions are the
whites you can see the state is a very
small part of the funding
and most of it is coming from
the public
who love their lakes
and then this is a
how much was asked for and how much was
given to grants
over the last
few years ending in 2020
and then here's a a quick overview of
the funding and where it comes from and
as you can see 35 percent is private
money
municipalities 46 and the state 19
and this was a study put up by the
ossipee lake alliance
and so the threat is serious and
economic impacts recreational impacts
and if it was uncontrolled it could
devastate our tourism economy
and most of the activities are paid for
by boaters municipalities governments
and donations
so here's just another quick thing
and here's remember i showed you that
picture of asquam cove on the left with
all the plants and then as it is now you
can see the milfoil is totally gone
much nicer place to put your boat in not
have milfoil getting wrapped up in the
propeller
and here are the members of the
committee
uh for this session
and now you can see it you know we have
people from all different uh agencies
and then different companies and
also public members
and that is the end of the slide show
and we would love to hear
if anyone has any questions
well thank you we appreciate that i'll
start one off i guess so the the state
voting registration fees or the voting
registration fees which bucket to those
go in the state or the municipal bucket
i'm going to uh
have amy address all those kind of
questions sure thanks
thank you chairman for the record my
name is amy smagula and i'm a biologist
with the department of environmental
services
uh
and these are the folks who give the
presentation for the committee but i'm
glad to answer the questions so the vote
registration fees are
there are multiple fees within the vote
registration
fee
and the money is directed to the
department of department of safety who
collects the fees and they transfer them
to def so it's kind of a
meandering path but ultimately the
funding comes directly to us
so is that counted in the the state
portion or the municipal contribution
portion that would be the state portion
and about three quarters of the state
portion goes right back out as grants to
other entities and then they come up
with other local match
great
all right i'll open it up look so we've
got multiple i'll start with the
representative aaron thank you and good
morning that was a wonderful
presentation by the way and i appreciate
you coming in to do this
i'm interested to know and
other
invasive species do you include also
yellow iris the yellow yeah yeah you are
correct we do include that one as a
state-listed invasive and how pervasive
is that
it's scattered around the state we've
mostly noticed it in southern portions
of new hampshire along riverways so
there are where where it is there are
locally large stands of it but it's not
extremely widespread across the state
yet
okay thank you very much
representative comptoin
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
my town
every year since i can remember for the
last 20 years has
voted to
fund milfoil
um
[Music]
divers and
excavation in our town we have a town
with over five bodies of water
we have seen a decrease in that through
the contin the annual
um
upkeep with that
i'm wondering how many other towns and
cities contribute
to
to the treatment of their water
and if you're seeing an improvement and
if they're doing it on a yearly basis
yeah that's a great question so
right now we have about 50 to 60
different towns and
towns and league associations that
contribute annually for control actions
and we have seen that the rate of spread
has gone down as a result of the
prevention efforts and the management
efforts have been successful in reducing
the overall footprint in in water bodies
go ahead and follow it yes thank you
so um
the other municipalities and towns that
don't contribute any funds
um is the state then
being the the sole resource for
controlling milfoil or any other
aquatics invasive species in those
waterways no unfortunately if there's no
local match we are not able to award
grants to local entities
so the first time a new infestation is
documented we can pay a hundred percent
of the control
after that we need match funds so for
perspective it took about five million
dollars last year to control invasive
aquatic plants in about 50 water bodies
this year it will be about six million
dollars and des is able to offer 50
grants
we just don't have the money to cover
six million dollars worth of control
efforts on ourselves and as you remember
in the presentation
there were 91 water bodies that are
infested so we're only managing just
over half
thank you just one more follow-up
question
so those municipalities
um or towns that don't invest in their
water uh ways
are basically ignoring the tourism value
uh to their towns
what how do we get them to start
investing
what is what is it through education of
the public um and how do we do that and
how do we create an outreach for them
yeah that's a great question i i think
continued um exploration of other
options too so a lot of those water
bodies are either river systems that go
through many towns or they're very small
lakes that don't have an established
lake association to be direct advocates
for those water bodies so for the larger
systems where there are multiple towns
involved
it's sometimes hard to get all of that
involvement across a river course
because once it's in a different town it
it's hard to piece it together um and
then for the smaller leak associations
that's challenging because there's not
somebody to lead the charge locally to
ask for
a conservation commission
allocation or a warrant article or
something like that
so i'm happy to continue reaching out to
those groups but unless there's a local
entity that's engaged it's very hard to
keep momentum going
representative murray
thanks for taking my question so one of
the questions i did have was around
those smaller lake associations do they
then network with regional lake
associations or do you see anything that
kind of helps
connect those folks together if they are
smaller to advocate together
i have not seen the smaller leaks
network as much there just isn't a lot
going on on those systems they sort of
don't have a lot of volunteer efforts
going on for weed watching
they don't have
even a lake association in place to
collect dues or to bring people together
it's sort of every person for themselves
on those types of lakes and that's hard
because you really do need people
rallying around that issue so it's
momentum building i think
thank you and then so if if one of these
smaller lakes were to discover that
there were an issue
um they would simply then have to know
where to go or who to reach out to
if there is a problem and you had
indicated the first instance is 100
covered and then after that
50 this year
yep okay so um
that's a great resource to know that is
available out there and i guess um
it's really encouraging to me to at
least know that there's something there
that
that knowledge can then be shared among
the smaller networks so thank you yeah
sometimes um what happens is that if
people find something and they don't
know where to go with it they'll start
with
you know uh unh or they'll start with a
different state agency and then it
eventually comes to me and once i
identify it it's just it's the tangled
pathway to finding the answer to a
question i think that we've all gone
through but once they get there i'm glad
to help them through the process it's
just yeah it's finding the right path
thank you
hi there thank you so much for that
presentation that was actually very
informative uh the question i had was do
you have sort of a
discount sheet or something that we
could provide
to our uh our towns that can at least
give them some give some information on
the matching funds and things for them
to consider of course yeah we do have a
lot of resources on our website but we
also have
little fact sheets and and card stock
material that conveys the message of if
you find something reported and then we
will work with you to help you get
through the process
so i can i can send some to the
committee
um on your website you have information
on the matching funds and grants right
so if somebody was referred there they
could find that all that right there
okay absolutely thank you it's on the
department of environmental services
website thank you yes
any further questions
go ahead rip tutsi um
yes thank you
um nashua just opened up i think it was
last year the year before a new boat
ramp on the
merrimack river
um has new hampshire lakes been in touch
with the merrimack river
what is it the lakes association yeah
right right exactly
to do anything in terms of educating
voters or
setting up your
educational
um
um yeah i don't i don't know the answer
to that new hampshire lakes is focused
on
on lakes in new hampshire if um if there
were another local group like merrimack
river watershed council
we would certainly partner with them or
and help share information but our
funding and our resources go primarily
to lakes
okay thank you
representative sanborn
you got to turn your mic on
there you go that's on
okay
um invasive species are they affected by
water temperature like will they
uh
grow more if the water's warm or
yeah definitely so warmer water makes
for a faster growth rate and some of the
scary statistics that we've seen of some
of the plants milfoil will grow an inch
a day
in the summer months when the water
temperatures are in the 70s
other plants that we don't have yet that
we that we really don't want is one of
them's hydrilla that grows six inches a
day so the growth is rapid and it is
accelerated by warmer water temperature
and on top of that as our water's warm
we will have other species from down
south which are even more potentially
invasive
come our way and
add to our list of infestations most
likely
thank you
anybody else
all right well i don't see any further
questions but i again want to thank all
of you that was a very informative
presentation and we appreciate you
taking the time and coming in and
if there's uh anything you need from us
as a committee going forward certainly
reach out and oh repremola has another
question can we get a copy of the slides
oh that'd be great super
well again if there's anything else that
we can help you with as you go forward
stuff you know information that we need
or
issues you that we need to help you with
certainly let us know and we'll do our
best to do so great thank you and it's
been great to be here great thank you
so we'll be uh
in recess until 10 a.m we will take up
our first hearing which is senate bill
every fall they cut it down and it grows
right up thick and like between rides
and stuff
gives like a privacy
yeah
the only place i've seen it any good
oh god me too
yeah it's a problem
oh
all that stuff
all right good morning everyone it is uh
1001 and i
want to welcome you back to the
environment and agricultural committee
we're going to open up the hearing on
senate bill 267 and i'm going to call on
senator
guida to introduce the bill
welcome senator dna thank you mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record bob guidas senate district 2
and prime sponsor of senate bill 267 fna
as you travel around the state
uh you will begin to notice entire areas
of forestry that are dying and you'll
notice japanese knotweed that's invading
our our streets our communities and so
forth those are but two of the numbers
of invasive upland species
uh that are
literally uh taking over much of our our
forests and our and our meadows and so
forth so
uh the origin of this bill uh was that
very uh that very problem we have no
coordinated statewide approach to deal
with
uh upland invasive species
unlike the water side of the house in
which aquatic invasive species are very
carefully monitored by des and and they
have a program and it's well established
and funded
so in the interests of protecting our
forests protecting our landowners and
our private property as well i brought
forth 267 fna
and does three things
it sets uh up a position of upland
invasive species program coordinator in
the department of agriculture's markets
and foods and i worked with the
commissioner on developing this
this bill
is not a permanent fix it's intended to
get us into the next budget cycle
at which point we would anticipate a new
position being established to coordinate
this for the state this bill gets it
started gets things you get some
equipment in
uh perhaps a location so forth and so
the funding for the bill is actually in
the text of the language uh the text of
the bill itself
it establishes the upland invasive
species remediation program and fund and
it makes an appropriation to that fund
of 150 000 dollars
with that that's pretty much the bill
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you senator and sarah any
questions for senator gaga
representative dutzy yes thank you thank
you for taking my question i know right
now we have a gentleman by the name of
doug saigon who works
in agriculture and he's kind of the
go-to guy for invasive plants and
everything
oh
you know i think there's a lot of
education that's that's being done about
that and i think a lot of conservation
commissions around the state are working
on that
why um you know isn't isn't that enough
isn't that enough that's being done why
would this bill be needed
coordinating position across the state
what's being done is basically voluntary
he does a good job but we need more
again the invasive species are exploding
uh and to as a state i think we have an
obligation to look into and to fund or
certainly establish a centralized
clearinghouse for information
uh a perhaps a a person or a
that would begin to look to legislation
for funding for programs to get rid of
this stuff because it is invasive and
and it's very difficult to get rid of
d.o.t
has an invasive species program but it's
only related to highways and state
highways which
by far are not the vast majority of the
lands in the state
so
if you in the in in the
in the bill you'll read that it the
coordinator would make maps of statewide
invasive species infestations notify
municipalities
hold a valid commercial category be
pesticide application license maintain
an active integrated vegetation
management program
basically sets up a system for this
person to then systematize attacking
this stuff across the state
let's follow it
yeah i'm sorry just to follow up
so i'm on the nashua conservation
commission and we do a lot with invasis
invasives and we work a lot with the
state
so what you're telling me right now
uh already in in my opinion already goes
on i mean in other words as as a
community
uh i mean there aren't there
statewide maps in granite for example i
mean if we come across an invasive
species in nashua
uh then we have the opportunity to to
map that out and grant it and i believe
this is a statewide map that's
that's available to everybody we also
work with
unh extension on this
so
you know from my perspective this is
already being done so i just need more
enlightenment on that well it's being
done by a volunteer right now
and is being done in an uncoordinated
way there's nothing of this nature up in
my part of the state the 27 towns that
represent most of them don't even have a
conservation commission
so this is a statewide problem
and it requires a statewide oversight to
coordinate what's going on because these
invasive species don't care if it's in
nashua it floats down the river a bird
carries it over the next thing you know
it's up in the north country so you need
a statewide coordinator to deal with
this problem it's been going on and
increasing and getting worse and worse
and worse and despite individual
communities that have both the personnel
resources as volunteers and perhaps paid
staff and the funding in their tax base
most of our communities do not have that
that's an amendment and it is not
exactly what was talked about with you
so um i'll explain
representative compta
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question
as representative dutsy spoke to
unh extension um does a lot with that
and then most of the counties also have
a um
conservation district person that they
pay on staff to help with all of this
so now what you're and we also deal with
the nrcs the national resource
committees
in our counties
so why are we going to add a
another position
when we're already funding unh extension
the county conservation
people
and also
have
access to nrcs
so i'm just wondering why we're going to
ask for more funding for this issue when
i i believe
at least in my county
we take it seriously and we have a lot
of people working on this program i
would judge from the proliferation of
invasive species around the state that
whatever is happening is not being
coordinated and it isn't working
for the most part and so again
since our forests are a state resource
not a county resource
and the private ownership our private
properties
extend across the entirety of the state
i think it makes a great deal of sense
to establish a statewide coordinator to
coordinate all of this stuff there's no
requirement for the for the university
system to oversee any of this
um and again
as we sit here
uh this stuff continues to proliferate
and there are no multiple other species
as well that are invasive that are
growing so
while it's nice that we have these
organizations that are not currently
coordinated i think a statewide
coordinator makes a great deal of sense
representative bixby yes thank you
thank you for taking my question
um so
something that uh representative pearl
noted to me and i um
agree in turn with his concern uh
in uh roman numeral one
uh at the end of the the first paragraph
before the bulleted list
it says upland invasive species program
coordinate coordinator shall
and then if you go down to
h
coordinate with state and federal
agencies municipalities universities
non-governmental environmental
organizations the general public and
others to help manage educate and raise
awareness of invasive species and i'm
sure the chair's concerned that having
that shall there
may in fact put an obligation on all of
the entities in that list
and
i
made an amendment which
i just handed to you which
can which changes the word coordinate to
um
uh to invite participation of
and that takes the obligation off of
those uh those organizations so um
i was wondering if you would be in favor
of that uh amen um sure
i don't see that as problematic in fact
yeah i would support such an amendment
and uh representative pearl also
uh had some issue with
the uh including uh non-governmental
environmental organizations
i personally
think that they would be involved
that it makes sense to involve them and
to specify them because they are a
significant stakeholder
but um that's i i was wondering if you
could address if you have um an opinion
about that or not
yeah i have concerns that if we
incorporate
ngos we start making this a political
issue
that's not what this commit this
position or this program is about
they're certainly welcome to participate
and testify at hearings and so forth
but i do have a concern
about ngos
attempting to hijack something rather
than just participating in a discussion
uh as if you will a witness to a
particular bill or a program
okay so um just as um
so i had i had a
different amendment uh drafted that i
had intended to in re re remove that
term but only half of the term got
removed
so uh
so i'm going to need to go back to ols
so um
if um if the committee feels that uh it
makes sense to remove that uh
that the the non-governmental
environmental organizations then i can
change the amendment to
to deal with that
i would leave that to the discretion of
the committee
thank you
any further questions representative
comtel
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
again um how will this will this have
any impact on the aquatic invasive
species program that we now have in the
state no no it will not um
while the commit it's envisioned that
this person
and this program would certainly
coordinate
with it does not have any impact on
funding
positions or any other functions of the
aquatic invasive species program
any uh representative aaron
thank you senator guida for coming today
and introducing this to us to our
committee
my question is
you had mentioned about
how this position would be funded in the
next budget cycle could you talk about
that a little bit more i mean
how we're looking at funding it
may be
initially here for this
uh non-non-budget year and then how that
would roll into the next budget cycle
sure thank you for the question it's a
good question
uh
in that
the individual who's feeling
voluntarily this function at agriculture
markets and foods
uh
is holding a position already what we
wanted to do was fund the tools for this
person to be able to function
still in that capacity essentially as a
volunteer and leave it to the next
legislature in the budget process i'm
reluctant to establish new positions in
the interim year between budgets that's
something that the legislature should
look at and that's the reason for
funding 150 000 for equipment
allowing this gentleman to continue to
do what he's doing
in preparation for uh you know the
discussion that will ensue regarding
invasive species in the next budget and
potentially establishing a position then
thank you
any further questions
seeing none we thank you
next we'll have uh represent
representative suzanne smith from
grafton8
good morning and welcome to ena and good
morning mr chair and members of the
committee and i am not representing
aquatic invasive species right now
but upland invasive species and i am in
full support of senate bill 267 of which
i am a co-sponsor
and i am a member of hebron's
conservation commission and we recently
held an invasive species day in the fall
where we came up with like 20 foot long
bittersweet roots and
autumn olive
barberry multiflora rosa and then along
our roads as many of you probably have
we have knotweed growing
and it takes a diligent effort by
volunteers to
try to remediate these things and i
often will make phone calls probably
once a year to mr seigens at des at a
department of agriculture markets and
food
who as
the senator said pretty much has added
on taking care of upland invasives to
his regular job
and in and he's been very good at it but
this coordinator position i think is
really important as we heard earlier in
the presentation those of you who were
here for the presentation of the aquatic
invasives
des has a biologist who is in charge of
aquatic invasive species at des and i
think that upland invasives are
as huge an issue and probably even more
so because they're not just in water
they're all over the place
and so this position i think is really
important
and i know there was talk there people
were asking questions about conservation
commissions already doing this but in my
area around newfound lake
and that whole watershed
half of the towns don't have
conservation commissions
some have no idea what they even look
like and i still get a lot of questions
from people saying
well why is bittersweet bad why can't i
pick the berries and put them on my
wreath in them you know at christmas
time
and it's you know so it's a challenge
education is a challenge and one of the
things i particularly like about this
bill
is that one person from each
municipality will be designated to be
the in-charge person and that person
will probably have a little more
education than
uh the rest of the public and so they
will be able to work more one-on-one
with the invasive species
program coordinator
and the education that can be provided
to community members
uh isn't just pulling up the weeds it
require you know and in the bill if you
look at
um the
in the uh d line 12 d maintain an active
integrative vegetation management
program that includes a combination of
mechanical cultural biological and
chemical controls to prevent and
inhibit the spread of invasive species
so the
people the designated person in each
town
can be working with their team to
evaluate what is going on and that try
to use the
integrative management you know with the
pulling and the mechanical means and
then go to the coordinator to say okay
we can't deal with this the knotweed is
just too prolific
and in my town i want to say and i'm not
a proud of this but a couple of people
went out and decided they were going to
get rid of the knotweed and without
having a license or doing anything they
went out and started just like spraying
roundup
on the knotweed which you know helped
that year but didn't do any good for the
watershed so i think this is a really
important uh bill and i think that this
program coordinator and
then the outreach to the communities is
also very important and needed at this
time in the state
so i can take questions but that's
pretty much all i had to say
all right do we have any questions for
representative smith representative
dotsy
uh yes thank you for taking my question
that's one of the issues that i have
with the bill
in that you talk about a let's say a
municipal coordinator okay
um i look at nashua and everybody in our
community planning department is you
know probably has about a hundred and
ten percent of their job already defined
so who is this person going to be
in and especially in a small town who is
this person going to be
i think that is up to the town and in my
town i can bet almost anything it's
going to be someone on the conservation
commission
so that's another volunteer
oh yeah i mean i mean it's either
someone who is getting paid like the
compliance officer or someone like that
may choose to do it because
um it is that person will also if
they're going to be using possibly
herbicides will need to be have be a
licensed applicator so it's up to the
community to figure it out and i would
think as a member of the conservation
commission i would be working with other
people in the community to say okay who
can we do this to who can we add this to
their job or do we have a volunteer who
wants to do this because they're going
to be educated doing it and also will be
able to
get an herbicide license if they're
interested and then be able to use that
for
other jobs that they're doing okay thank
you
any further questions
seeing none thank you okay thank you
very much
next we will have pierre siegert from uh
department of ag
thank you and that was great
pronunciation of my name i was that was
very i have an advantage i've seen it
before
thank you and welcome to dna well thank
you so piera siegert i'm the state
entomologist and the director of the
division of plant industry i'm here
representing the new hampshire
department of agriculture markets and
food
we are in support of this bill and
provided input to senator guida as he
was drafting it um i didn't have any
further comments but there do seem to be
some questions about how the invasive
species program currently works in the
department and i would be happy to
entertain those
all right i actually have one about the
bill itself a question and i'm not sure
if you'll be able to answer it it might
need to go to david russo the
line 15
section one the it the
coordinator shall purchase herbicides in
bulk in order to reduce purchasing costs
municipalities
having a strong background in the sale
of pesticides
we actually would he actually be allowed
to do this and distribute to
municipalities without running into a
licensing issue that would be a better
question for david russo okay i'm sorry
that's fine i kind of looked at that
just now and it caught my attention i
know it's kind of a technical question
but all right that's fair enough any
other questions
you may get off really easy
[Laughter]
i'm ready but
all right well anything further you want
to add
um
i guess i guess i would just reiterate
that on the ground watching how this
program works there's essentially two
areas of focus in in the division about
upland invasive species uh maybe three
if i add an outreach so the first is
that a number of plants on the
prohibited invasive plant list have in
traditionally been nursery stock plants
and so a big focus in the division right
now is ensuring that those are not being
offered for sale um through the
nurseries and i have four people in the
division all of us do some nursery
inspections and so all four of us are
kind of attending to the to the um
to the nursery stock pathway
another area of focus is outreach and i
i think that we've got excellent
outreach materials about all of these
invasive plants we've got the prohibited
invasive upland species guide which is
i can't remember which edition has been
reprinted recently but it's in constant
demand by the towns um it's posted on
our website we have a japanese knotweed
best management practices manual that
was distributed to
all of the dot districts as well as i
think the towns
that's also available on their website a
lot of other states do request
use of some of the outreach materials
that we have developed
all of that is being funded through
ipm grants requested from
the ipm fund
there's no dedicated fund for those
outreach materials and then the third
part is
the part which is more related to
management and that really is utilizing
mr saigan's experience with other state
agencies and with the extensive amount
of outreach that he has done with towns
over the years to try to
work on some projects there is our
projects with dot for controlling
japanese knotweed
along roadways
none of that has any funding behind it
in terms of how it is managed and so
that's with pesticides that are
purchased by dot
with equipment that's purchased by dot
and then time from the department of
agriculture for for doug's time in
training and applying herbicides uh and
so the benefit that i see to the um
to this bill is the hundred and fifty
thousand dollars of seed funding um that
would you know be more than what is
currently allocated to the invasive
species program um in order to extend
the program to towns that maybe are not
as well established with their county
conservation districts and their in
their town responses
all right
rep pamola
so you may have inspired a question well
i'm just curious what is the current
funding then if you said if the 150 000
exceeds it right now there's no
allocation for for treatment of invasive
plants thank you
representative dutzy
uh yes thank you
so my understanding going back is that
when conservation
when the law allowed conservation
commissions it was actually enabling
legislation
so
if a
town has chosen not to have a
conservation commission
why would we think that they would um
have the personnel or the interest in
doing something with invasives
i don't know how to answer exactly the
question you just asked me in all
fairness um i i will say
um that
you know there's a lot of local control
here right and so if a town isn't
interested
you know i don't know that you would
have them be interested
we do get a lot of calls from different
towns
requesting doug's ability to give
presentations requesting information on
invasive species and i believe that unh
extension did put together a survey
several years ago with different
land managers
pesticide applicators groups that are
involved with invasive species in terms
of what they saw the needs were to
further develop the programs and they
did say better coordination was it was
one of the needs that they had cited
there
and i know i did not directly answer
your question i'm sorry about that
any further questions
all right seeing none
so that's all the cards i have on this
is refamila if you get the blue sheet
for me anybody else i would like to
testify on 267 before i close it
so online we have
14 people that signed in in support
of the bill left house senate bill 267
and on the blue sheet we have four
people signed in also all in support
all right with that we're gonna close
senate bill 267 and we will
recess until 10 30 we will open the next
bill
please
the next one's at 20 30.
um
initially
good morning senator are you all set to
go
okay see it's uh 10 30 we're going to
open up the hearing on senate bill 379
and i will call on senator waters to
introduce the bill
as soon as he's ready sorry let's put
you on a little quicker there
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee welcome to e-night
nice to see you all senator david waters
from district four introducing senate
bill 379 establishing the solid waste
management fund and
grant program
um i don't need to tell you there's just
a lot of activity around solid waste
we're trying in many ways as we can not
just about the dalton situation but more
generally about solid waste and as you
know
the house bill that established the
study committee is doing great work and
the bill we passed last year which
required the des to develop a 10-year
plan which had been in hiatus for solid
waste management and reduction and there
are lots of other bills about you know
how do we reduce the stream and uh of
that and encourage more recycling and
what are we going to do about siting
facilities well let's see if we can't
i'll be you know obviate the need for
that by dealing with our our waste
so i worked
with
des and others
to develop this bill which will help us
prepare for this changing landscape by
establishing
a fund
that would be available
with the parameters to find the bill for
federal funding that we expect to
receive for solid waste management
there's a lot of bill a lot of money in
an infrastructure bill
potentially from other sources as well
particularly through epa
grant funds that we do expect to receive
and we'll be able to use to manage
solid waste
so um and i think also that having a
dedicated fund with some legislative
language around its purpose will give us
a leg up
on applying for funding because it shows
that we have a vehicle and legislative
intent around it
so the heart of it
is what we can do with it starting on
line 22 and you know over the last
couple of years all the debates on the
bills these seem to be
the things that we think we could do the
most good with the funding that we're
going to receive
so
let's help out new hampshire
municipalities
and private entities and businesses
for projects
that will help
to
improve waste diversion methods
it could be
helping
one of our municipalities get a
compactor
equipment uh develop more recycling um
programs uh businesses to help reduce
their
waste stream um so those are the kinds
of uh things that you know
municipalities and others are really are
really uh
for
last we've got to reduce waste but you
know we're in the era of pfas folks and
other
toxic materials that we don't want our
landfills so here
how to reduce hazardous waste materials
and what might this fund do to provide
grants so that we can do that reduction
and uh
diversion of of those
um and then the fund we ought to
identify that um you know we're not
seeking new employees here um
through state appropriations saying that
you know you can
use the fund as it comes in um
to hire consultant contractors necessary
expenses uh involved with managing the
fund and getting grants out and then top
of page two
the epa is the agency that has these
monies deposited in it that can go out
to the states
that the
commissioner can do rulemaking involved
in the grant grant programs and uh the
you know how matching funds are gonna be
determined and and gotten out to
uh
folks um we're gonna get reports
on the activities as the funding
uh is is used and then um
some
you know kind of details that fall out
uh from that so the bill itself is
fairly simple setting up the fund saying
this is what it's for and we're
anticipating this this money
and this at least let us do do something
to help out with the solid waste issues
that we're facing so thank you mr
chairman
do you have time for any questions or do
you need to run
do you have time for questions or do you
need your own
representative bixby
thank you senator thank you for taking
my question uh
so
uh one uh
thing that i'm kind of wondering about
is the long-term sustainability of the
funding for this i
there is currently grant money available
apparently at the federal level
what happens uh four or five years down
the road do we
then get into a situation where we have
been funding something for a little
while and then we
no longer have the funding for that
similar to how we funded solid waste
programs in the late 90s early 2000s and
then
we
that that division has shrunk to not
um
sort of a skeleton crew
yeah thanks for your question
representative and
uh you know who knows the future right
i will say this
that the fund will have a immediate
purpose now and be useful for the state
of new hampshire and that's who i'm
interested in the state of new hampshire
i do suspect
that given the national scope of this
problem and its ongoing nature that
whatever party may be in control down in
washington
all both members of both parties and you
know whoever is president knows
that the states are facing these issues
so i would expect as in the past and in
the future that there will be
federal attention and potentially funds
for us to apply for but but we don't
know but for right now
this will help we'll get some money out
we'll help some municipalities and
businesses and
that's to the thank you
representative aaron
you you're telling me when you don't
have time for any more questions i know
you have another obligation to be here
thank you mr chair maybe maybe one one
more time
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
waters for coming thank you hi i'm back
here
on the way
uh so i have a couple of questions um
one do you have any idea
how much money is anticipated
from the federal government for this
these
programs and what could potentially
be placed into this fund and will we be
seeding this fund with anything to begin
with
um
i'm trying to check on my notes is
somebody from
you're going to talk about it okay thank
you
okay i think there is some idea but i i
just have a feeling that
i'm going to say the wrong number all
right good enough thank you
fair enough representative compton
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my questions
um my question is
what type of federal strings will be
attached by accepting any of these funds
well thanks for your question and um you
know what you know funds can be
appropriated but then they have to write
the regulations for how you can use them
and that's pretty typical about
everything we get from the federal
government there's nothing in this bill
that requires us to accept those funds
if we think the regulations are
inappropriate for
for new hampshire and that's also why
rulemaking is in here that if we have a
certain guard rails on the regulations
for receiving the funds the rulemaking
can be the process where we figure out
how to make that work for
for new hampshire thank you do you have
time for one more are you sure all right
representative
oh you got it all right
seeing no more i appreciate you coming
in thank you so much thank you so much
appreciate it any and of course if there
are any questions that come up after
this about changes you want or anything
like that please let me know mr chairman
certainly will yeah
representative evil did you want to
speak okay i don't have a pink card for
you so
i'll have you come up and you can fill
one out after if you would
my apologies i found another stack of
them over here representative evil okay
well thank you very much thank you mr
chairman uh for the record my name is
karen ebel
um i represent merrimack district five
which is new london and
newbury
and i'm here in support of
sb 379
which i'm also a co-sponsor i just want
to say it's really uh nice to be back
with uh trash
aficionados i've been uh talking a lot
of trash lately i know you do too so um
feels like home again or sort of um
so the the basis of this bill is to
create a
solid waste management fund and i know
you just heard the outlines of it from
senator waters and i also think you know
some of the history but i'll just go
through it really quickly and i had more
of it in my written testimony
through the
hb617 recycling and solid waste study
committee we analyzed many things
and one of the things that really
left to the forefront was that a fund
was needed or some funding was needed to
help des better perform its job in
planning and solid waste management and
we also needed some help from
municipalities who were really feeling
the impact of having to deal with their
trash in a in a global economy that as
you know china stopped taking a lot of
the plastics and mixed paper and there
was just a lot of confusion and turmoil
out there
many things have happened since 2019
when we first did that recycling
study committee there's now a huge
amount of focus on solid waste which is
a good thing because i think it's been
neglected for too long
and a lot has also happened
we have established new solid waste
diversion goals we have a long range
solid waste plan which we're promised
will be available to us on october 1st
and we know that that hasn't been
prepared since 2003
we have a reorganization in des that
includes now um two planning folks one
just joined yesterday
and we also have formed the solid waste
working group of which i am a cha i'm
the chair and uh representative pearl is
a member
there's a renewed focus on landfilling
and more and more people have come to
understand that as far as the private
landfills are concerned at least half of
the
solid waste coming into the state is
from elsewhere
and there's a lot of study committees
being formed so we know that there's a
lot of interest
but at some point
very soon and i'd like to say now the
rubber is going to hit the road
actions are going to have to be taken
that
you know sometimes we're slow to take in
the state of new hampshire we have to
stop saying no to some of these actions
things that include funding things that
include potentially
some requirements waistbands there's all
sorts of things but if you're going to
meet your solid waste diversion goals
which we adopted wholeheartedly here in
the legislature and the governor signed
we're going to have to do things and one
of the things that's going to be very
important
is to
start to create funding that can help
support infrastructure so that if you
really uh renew your focus on renew
reuse and recycling there are facilities
to recycle
so one of the goals of this solid waste
management fund is to
help support the development of the
infrastructure among other things to
support municipalities doing a better
job recycling expanding their recycling
capabilities
and
all these things will take money now
i just was at a conference and i just
want to mention this because you're the
you're the um
committee where a lot of these measures
are going to be discussed i mean the the
solid waste working group and all these
study committees can make a lot of
recommendations
but it's going to have to take a lot of
policy willpower to put these things
into um
into being so at this conference we were
talking about the chicken and the egg
theory do you require recycling do you
ban c and d
from going into a landfill unless it's
15 percent recycled like some states are
doing do you ban
mattresses from going into landfills and
where's the recycling capability what's
the chicken in the egg can you ban it
and hope that the infrastructure will
develop or do you develop the
infrastructure and then institute the
ban probably the way these things are
going to happen is they're going to
happen together and we're going to need
some
stimulus funding
to help those get going well fortunately
the federal government has recognized
this and in the last um the the
infrastructure bill
and
director wimsat is here so i but i hope
i have my numbers straight i understand
that there's 275
million dollars that's being
appropriated
for uh recycling and
solid waste efforts which i think is
fantastic news at this conference the
epa
representative said that in her career
she's never seen this much money come
forward for solid waste efforts uh she
said that 55 million dollars per year is
going to be appropriated and the
states can
request
grants and there was a question about
strings attached any grant you know you
request there will be certain
requirements in order for you to get the
grant so you'll have to fulfill those so
it depends on what you're asking for but
the other
exciting news that the epa
representative shared was that included
in that funding
every state will definitely get
some amount of money for solid waste
efforts and she wasn't really able to
say exactly how much that money would be
so we know right out of the block
we should be able to get federal funding
for this solid waste
management fund
i would be remiss if i didn't say that
the recommendation for the solid waste
management fund did come out of the hb
617 study committee and initially we
were talking about a solid waste
dispersal uh disposal surcharge on
tipping um costs so for every ton that
you put in a landfill
in the original version of the bill
1.50 would have to be paid and that was
going to be one of the funding sources
with response to you representative
bixby
for this fund and it would help create a
grant program
to go back to municipalities but as far
as out of state waste was concerned
our municipalities would get it back but
out of state waste wouldn't necessarily
uh the the people who dumped it wouldn't
get it back that has been removed from
the bill
in the original amendment that was in
the senate five hundred thousand dollar
appropriation was put in the bill that
was removed by finance
the governor was opposed to the
surcharge but he did say that if we
needed funding there was plenty of
surplus and that
we should be able to put some money in
for
for seed money for this but at this
point there's no money in it you're
right and i'm just going to reiterate
what i said before at some point the
rubber is going to meet the road here
and we're going to have to take some
actions that we don't always like to
take in the state of new hampshire
otherwise our landfills are going to
continue to be brimming and we're going
to have to accept out-of-state waste
because we may have to build new
landfills to accept everything so
i would encourage this committee to
recommend passage of this fund as a way
of helping us accomplish goals that we
really need to accomplish in the state
and i'd be happy to take any questions
thank you representative any questions
uh representative murray
hi thank you mr chair for taking my
question thank you representative evil
um so my question is actually around
shared waste disposal districts and
do you have any idea of how those might
um
would this be worked out in rules like
how how would they potentially apply for
some of these things well i think that's
probably a question for direct director
wimsat
and i think we have to see also what the
federal requirements are and and how all
that will work but you know we do talk a
lot about municipalities but of course
one really important
entity in the state of new hampshire is
the solid waste district and we want to
make sure to support those
and interestingly as you know
municipalities solid waste districts
they are not subject to the interstate
commerce clause so they have control
over the waste that they that they um
can take
thank you representative bixby
thank you chairman thank you
representative ebel um
so i have a question
that
gets to
um
it's on line 10 of page two
administration of solid waste management
fund rsa
149 m6
uh 11 is repealed and reenacted as
follows and i um
took the liberty of looking up what uh
149 m611 roman 11 is
and it is a an existing one dollar
surcharge on out of waste state a one
dollar per ton surcharge on out of waste
out of state solid waste
and so what is the history of that
surcharge and um
i i kind of understand with the current
intent why it's being removed but what's
the history of that surcharge
well um i will tell you what i've
learned because i've learned oh so many
things about solid waste in the last
several years but you know the um
the issue of the state of new hampshire
accepting out-of-state waste has been
out there for a really long time
and there was an attempt
to place a fee on just of state waste in
the statutes but no sooner did the
legislature pass it then
we were told by the attorney general
that it's illegal to only put a fee on
out of state waste and it's been
lingering there
hopefully no
in our in our statutes um and uh in an
effort to sort of clear the books of
things that aren't really legal
the
we went ahead and put the repeal of that
statute in this bill
thank you
any further questions
all right seeing none what we think do
we have one representative control i'm
sorry i didn't see you
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um
just want to go into a little bit more
depth
regarding out-of-state waste and
municipalities
can you explain
um right now it's we have to accept
out-of-state waste is that correct
well stated in the reverse you can't ban
it
right so if you're a private landfill
you don't have to accept it but we can't
ban it under the interstate commerce
close clause follow it please thank you
um
so
when you talked about like there is like
municipal you know solid waste districts
where there's like four towns that get
together um they can control um out of
state but individual
uh cannot is that my understanding
yeah
follow up
on more sure yeah so
with
this funding coming in is there is is
part of it to help
prohibit out-of-state waste from coming
into the state is
there any intention in this for that um
well
so the thing is if you're going to
just this is going to be a little bit of
a long answer but if you're going to
um
try to meet your diversion goals
one of the things that you can do and
what a lot of states do in fact we have
a couple on our books we don't allow
leaf and yard waste for instance in our
landfills but if for instance you wanted
to institute
a waistband on mattresses and it's the
second time i've mentioned them because
i've learned that that you know during
covet everybody wanted to replace their
mattress and they're just like filling
up the landfills but you couldn't like
say all right our our
landfills can only accept new hampshire
based mattresses you know you can't
so
what you would do is
you could institute a waistband
you could use some of the monies that
are in this fund
to try to develop a recycling program
for mattresses
and in that way you would be achieving
your
your diversion goal without outrightly
banning
out of state mattresses
but the effect might be overall
you're decreasing the amount of
out-of-state mattresses that end up in
our overloaded landfill
i hope that helps
okay
seeing no more questions we appreciate
your testimony and
well thank you for all your uh hard work
next we'll have uh nat grays from the
new hampshire municipal association
welcome to ena
thank you mr chair nate grace for the
new hampshire municipal association
it might surprise you all to learn that
we support this bill um it would uh
obviously assist municipalities quite a
lot
you know we don't have exact numbers on
what type of federal funding would be
available or how exactly the rules would
work out um
i believe that director wimsett would
would have uh probably a better
knowledge of that than i would
but we do understand that you know we
need a multi-faceted solution to the
landfill problem
uh and
we are committed to working with des and
all of our partners in the state to try
to
come to a solution that works as the
committee's already recognized you know
there are some hurdles with things like
the interstate commerce clause
that that do cause some issues in our
ability to
um
deal with the landfill capacity issue
this bill in particular would provide a
mechanism to help help municipalities
deal with existing issues as well as
future issues
as senator waters mentioned
would allow municipalities potentially
to purchase things that are often very
expensive for small municipalities with
transfer stations to purchase such as
skid loaders etc
by providing
matching grants depending on exactly
what what rules are
formulated here it would also serve to
help
both municipalities and
our our partners in the private industry
world innovate to
better reduce the amount of solid waste
go into landfills which as we've learned
through a very lengthy process so far
evaluating the the state landfill
capacity is something that will likely
become much more expensive and affect
municipalities and of course their
citizens
happy to answer any questions the
committee has
thank you any questions
see
representative stapleton
representative muller could you grab the
blue sheet for me
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i noticed in a previous testimony
submission
new hampshire's tipping fee is 80 a ton
to the landfill relative to
122 a ton massachusetts 116 vermont and
100 a ton in rhode island so it's no
wonder we have a lot of
uh out of state coming in here
and
to my way of thinking it sounds like
we're being gamed but
could
the municipalities and towns in new
hampshire sustain a higher than 80
dollars a ton landfill
to discourage or at least equalize to
the out of state the other state's fees
so one of the issues that comes up with
tipping fees of course is that they're
going to apply universally so we are
cheaper tipping fee than many other
states
which makes our state more attractive to
those waste operators to ship
materials here but at the same time it's
also the fee that our citizens pay
so there's a balancing act that the
legislature has to do in determining
what the appropriate amount is and
versus um
how attractive that will be to
out-of-state um
waste
up
what i was getting at there is there
room for
raising
that new hampshire tipping fee without
hurting the municipalities and towns
that uh really need
an advantage is there a balancing figure
there someplace have you ever talked
about that
that's really a policy decision that
goes beyond what we would we would
advocate for at the municipal
association
thank you
any further questions representative
murray
thank you mr chair for taking my
question and thank you for taking my
question
historically
the tipping fees have increased
exponentially over the last several
years could you speak a little bit to
that
i'm not as knowledgeable as
some of the people behind me are about
that but to the extent that i understand
it
you know
back in
uh i think 2018 2019 we saw a pretty big
shift in just the way solid waste is
managed because
um for example china shut off a lot of
imports of waste that were coming from
the united states as well as elsewhere
and all of these things are
really on an international economy and
so one of the
biggest struggles that municipalities in
new hampshire face is you know our
municipalities average size is under six
thousand people
and you're trying to deal deal with a
whole economy that relates on a global
scale so what happens in china indonesia
etc is affecting what the costs are here
in new hampshire
and that's really probably the most
difficult thing for us to deal with
and why a bill like this is important
because it really it really helps us
focus on things we can do at the local
level to help control costs
over the long term
thank you
any further questions
seeing none we thank you thank you okay
that's the last pink card i have anybody
in the audience that wishes to testify
representative representative i keep
elevating you that director whimsicott
yes
[Laughter]
thank you mr chairman
good morning i'm sorry it's a little
late so i'll provide a pink card after
my testimony for the record my name is
mike wimsat i serve as director of the
waste management division for the new
hampshire department of environmental
services
uh pleased to be here to testify and
support the senate bill 379.
as in a lot has been said here as with
the other witnesses so i don't know that
i need to spend too much time other than
to say that uh des supports this if
nothing else it shows a statement by the
legislature that it supports des making
efforts to try to incentivize recycling
and other forms of
technology for managing waste other than
landfill and incineration
by by potentially assuming that we can
get funding from the federal government
or other sources
by providing incentive grants and
matching grants to
municipalities solid waste districts and
private industry that will help to
advance that kind of infrastructure here
in our state uh to answer the question
that came up
regarding funding under the bipartisan
infrastructure law uh again uh
representative ebel had it right there's
uh i think actually the the numbers that
they depend they parse it out in a few
different ways it's about 350 million
dollars over five years that that bill
appropriates for for solid waste issues
and
much of that is to be dedicated to
grants for recycling not entirely clear
right now how epa will they're still
sorting it out themselves but not
entirely clear how they will choose to
administer that they may well make some
of their own grants directly to
applicants who come in looking for
grants but certainly a portion of its
substantial portion is expected to be
allocated
for grants to the states and once we
have a better idea what that looks like
certainly i think you know i hate to try
to
speculate what we might be able to
obtain but if we look at that kind of
level of funding and how it usually
translates to new hampshire
from the national level funding it's
very possible that we could
compete for or apply for a grant of
several hundred thousand dollars a year
over the next five years
that might allow us to make some really
and again that's against a backdrop
where we have no money for that right
now we make no incentive grants
whatsoever to advance or encourage um
recycling technologies so that's from
zero to whatever it is and that that
could be very substantial in a state
like new hampshire to help you know
advance some of these technologies and
i'll leave it at that and be happy to
answer any questions thank you any
questions representative murray
thank you mr chair for taking my
question thank you director wimsett just
to be clear this is a dedicated
non-lapsing fund is that correct that's
correct that's my understanding thank
you
any further questions
representative comptoa
thank you mr chair and thank you
director for taking my question um in
lou this says it's a non-lapsing fund
what happens when those federal the
grant funds run out
so um assuming that you know if if if
the fund is created and the only source
of funding that it ever gets is from
federal grants then likely what we would
do and again it has to be said we don't
know what these grants are going to look
like it's possible that epa would make
grants available that would do something
that's outside the realm of what the
fund has been intended for in which case
we could potentially go after those
grants and just
not put them in the fund just to
administer them through the normal grant
administration process which we do in a
number of programs at des but given that
the bipartisan infrastructure law is
intended to advance recycling and that's
what this fund is really about um we
would deposit those funds to to
those grant monies to the fund and
administer them um until until they ran
out and if they ran out we wouldn't do
it anymore but that's not inconsistent
with what we've done in many programs
there are lots of programs at des where
federal funding comes for a period of
time to accomplish a particular goal and
we go after those funds to the extent
it's appropriate with our mission and we
administer them accordingly and then
when they run out we we'd go back to
doing what we were doing before
representative aaron
thank you mr chair and thank you
director wimsat for coming and speaking
to us about this
proposed legislation i'm interested to
know in so far as the rulemaking
from
adopting rules
do you have an idea in
anticipation of how long though it takes
to get those rules put into place once
this fund is established
and um would the rules mirror what the
federal government guidelines
would dictate for
disbursement of these funds
so typically rulemaking takes if you
look at from
first conception of what you want to do
to actually have them implemented
you know
we've done it faster when we're in a big
rush and we know exactly what we want
but usually if you can count on about a
year to get those rules in place
um if if we know
what i would advocate i think for this
is to keep those rules very simple
because
one of the concerns is that if you if
you box yourself in with rules in a way
that means that that most of the money
that might come your way would not
comport with those then you haven't done
yourself any favors so we would look at
that very carefully and try to make sure
that the rulemaking we did
really was just procedural this is how
you uh how we advertise and how people
apply for a grant and this is how we
administer that grant and we we're not
inventing anything out of whole cloth
here des operates
a number of programs where federal
monies come to us and we we um
we implement
implement that um so it really depends
we have to look at it but again um
you don't want to do it in a way that
that makes your your rules basically
handcuff you to the point where you
can't accept or spend money
thank you
representative bixby
yes thank you chair thank you director
for taking my question uh
so
um is this
build uh aimed only at the
infrastructure funds or would you be on
the lookout for other granting
possibilities that could also fulfill
the purpose we would always be
interested in any funds that could come
our way to advance these these goals so
i i would not limit it to federal funds
through the bipartisan infrastructure
law at all thank you
anybody else representative amola
yes sir thank you for taking my question
and if you've covered this i'm sorry i'm
just i just missed this but for the
non-lapsing revolving fund obviously
we're talking about that it's for
federal federal dollars and when the
federal dollars ran out runs out the
non-lapse revolving fund stops is that
we're saying or does that get
supplemented with state funding at that
point
no i think as i understand it the fund
would
let's say for argument's sake that we
got five years of funding and we set
this program up and we put
that grant funding into this solid waste
management fund and administer it for
five years and then epa stops making any
further grants and we don't have any
other sources of money we would simply
uh you know administer the grant give
out all the grant money presumably and
then the the fund could still sit there
with a zero balance but it would still
exist and so that if something came
along
two years after that we could go after
it and put it back into the fund that's
that's why i would understand it okay
so just to clarify it does not obligate
us then at the state level to replenish
a certain amount that
um that had been granted
no i'm not i'm not aware that it
obligates us to anything of the sort the
the um uh
the only thing i will say is that if we
you know when we get a grant from epa it
has its own conditions they're the grant
giver they get to make the rules and so
we would there could be a situation
where and and we're pretty good at
spending money so i wouldn't think we'd
run into this but it could be a
situation where we get a grant and we
don't get the money out the door quick
enough and after a period of time epa
says we want the balance back in which
case we'd have to give it back to them
but you know that's something we strive
not to do once the epa gives us a grant
we try to use it
promptly
for the intended purpose thank you
any further questions
seeing none we thank your director
all right last call anybody else want to
testify seeing none i'm going to read
the blue sheet results we have two
people on the blue sheet signing in in
favor and we have 47 online signing in
in favor
and with that i'm going to close a
hearing on senate bill 379.
you
and now we will open up the hearing on
senate bill 380 and i will call on
senator hennessey to introduce the bill
welcome to the ena good morning
committee thank you mr chairman good
morning committee members aaron
hennessey i am the state center for
district one which is the northern half
of grafton county in all of coast county
as amended by the senate this bill does
two things and those two things go into
the same um ongoing working group and
that's um it amends the charge of the
solid waste working group or as members
on that committee like to call it the
swag
and
the house has a participant on that
committee it's representative ebel and
the senate also has a participant on
that committee and that's senator gray
and they are both in favor of this
and the two charges to that ongoing
committee or commission would be to
review and make recommendations
regarding municipal solid waste plans
and implementing the prohibition of any
landfill in the state from accepting
wastes for municipality that does not
have a solid waste management plan
now that's a
they would add that to the charge they
don't have to recommend that they just
have to look at that and what the
benefits um
or costs or um
negative effects of doing something that
like that would be
also to review and make recommendations
regarding the development of a solid
waste disposal site evaluation committee
or better defining alternative site
analysis in our current rsas and that's
what this bill does i'm happy to take
questions
there we go thank you uh representative
bixby
yes um thank you for taking my question
uh the
um
charge number one uh
we uh
looking at uh requiring municipal solid
waste plans uh for
being able to uh dump into a landfill
is
that uh
would that just cover
municipalities within the state of new
hampshire or would any
entity anywhere
in the world need to have a solid
a solid waste plan in order to
be able to dump into a new hampshire
landfill
so as the sponsor of this ideally it
would be everyone who would want to dump
something in new hampshire but that
would be up to the swag to determine how
they're going to review that and what
their recommendation again it would just
be a recommendation that they would make
to the legislature okay
but you are
you were hoping that this may be a way
of reducing the pressure of out of state
waste is that correct
i am hoping that um this is a way that
we can look at alternatives to disposal
in the state of new hampshire and not
putting as much
waste in the landfills okay thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you senator we
appreciate you coming in
next we will call representative ebel
welcome back again thank you
hello everyone for the record my name is
karen ebel merrimack district five new
london and newbury
um
and i am the chair of the swag
the name of which i like very much
and uh and
i
i'm not actually taking a position on
the bill i just want to say that i don't
have um i'm i'm fine with it i don't
really have
any objection to it
we are going you know the
although a lot of us are very focused on
the work that the swag is going to be
doing in anticipation of the long range
solid waste plan our
working group does have a five-year term
and we're going to be looking at
many many different things and we're
going to be continuing to work with the
department because as the department
will tell you and as we believe we think
the long-range plan will be a sort of a
living working document and so
as the swag makes recommendations as
their
as it's deemed appropriate to put into
the long-range plan as we come forward
to the legislature with ideas for
legislation um we're going to be looking
at any variety of subjects and these are
ones that um i'm more than happy to have
included in our charge
thank you any questions
representative comfort thank you mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question
when does the working group when is it
set to expire
well
it's five years and it's a november
first and i think it's 2026.
thank you yeah
i think you're right on that too i
believe it is 2026. yeah i think i think
that's right and i mean just by the way
uh
we are meeting monthly at this point um
but we would anticipate probably ramping
that up a little bit as we
work as as we come closer to the
production of the long-range plan
any further questions
seeing none thank you
uh director wimsat from new hampshire
des
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record again my name
is mike wimsett service director of the
waste management division for new
hampshire des
happy to be here to testify and support
the senate bill 380. um you know as
representative ebel indicated
these topics and many others are topics
that a lot of stakeholders in solid
waste are asking about and talking about
right now and from our perspective the
solid waste working group is the
appropriate forum to to explore and
discuss these issues the the committee
or the working group is comprised of
people with
various types of expertise and various
uh you know perspectives all related to
management of solid waste so we we feel
that these issues are certainly um you
know
appropriate to be before that working
group for consideration and discussion
and i'll be happy to answer any
questions
thank you doctor any questions
see none i think you're going to get off
easy this time
all right my final pink card so i would
ask representative muller to send the
blue sheet and if anybody else wants to
speak uh certainly get a card into me is
peter peter blair from the conservation
law foundation
good morning and welcome to ena good
morning it's a pleasure to be here i've
been peppering you with emails for the
greater part of i think a year and a
half and this is my first time actually
in person in your committee so very
happy to be here
thank you for the opportunity to provide
testimony in support of
sb 380 for the record my name is peter
blair i am the northern new england zero
waste staff attorney for conservation
law foundation clf strongly supports
sb380 we feel that the two changes to
the duties and responsibilities of the
solid waste working group are critically
important for better understanding and
evaluating the current waste management
systems in new hampshire
the first change would be that
evaluation of whether to prohibit
landfilling of waste from municipalities
that do not have a solid waste
management plan i would just like to
point out that currently new hampshire
municipalities are already required to
develop these plans
so it is not looking at increasing a
burden on new hampshire municipalities
just further understanding how they
manage their waste
what type of waste they're dealing with
and is that waste being
reduced and recycled prior to disposal
but importantly the current law does not
apply to out-of-state
municipalities as you've heard
throughout this session 50 percent of
the waste landfill in new hampshire
comes from out of state
by focusing on whether there should be a
prohibition on all municipalities that
do not have these plans you'd be taking
a holistic look on the amount of waste
that is coming into new hampshire and
whether that is being managed in
accordance with the state's requirements
and goals specifically the 50 reduction
goal that was passed last year
as for the second change in sb 380 clf
generally speaking is not supportive of
increasing disposal capacity in new
hampshire however if there is a need for
new disposal whether it be expanded
landfills or new landfills we do think
it is a good idea to
take an evaluation of how the state
currently looks at what is the proper
site for those landfills you've all
heard about the controversies
surrounding the currently proposed
granite state landfill in dalton
the development of a solid waste
disposal site evaluation committee or
looking at the current regulations which
relate to the alternative site analysis
will better understand
the range of opportunities there are to
figure out where is the appropriate
place we should be putting new disposal
capacity if it is necessary
so in conclusion we think that this bill
is smart it squarely fits within the
current duties and responsibilities of
the swag which is a wonderful name for a
very interesting committee
so thank you for your up the opportunity
to speak and i'll answer any questions
you have
well i'm proud to be a member of swag
[Laughter]
all right uh representative comfort
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so
when you were speaking you were saying
that you know based on how we're reading
this bill it would require any
municipality anywhere that brings in
solid waste to new hampshire to have a
solid waste management plan
how would we
now there are private companies that
also bring in
waste to new hampshire how would this
affect them
so it wouldn't impact private companies
but a significant amount of waste does
come from municipalities and looking at
whether
that way should be managed in accordance
with new hampshire's
reduction goals is really important
currently new hampshire has no say over
how the waste is being managed from the
municipalities outside of new hampshire
that are coming to private landfills
or even
the publicly owned ones so by looking
into this prohibition you'd be
essentially looking at what vermont has
done which vermont only has one landfill
they're very protective of it and
they've decided that they want to make
sure that every municipality that sends
waste to that single landfill has to
have this type of plan has to show that
they are managing their waste in a way
that is reducing it complying with their
hierarchy meeting their waste reduction
goals so it wouldn't deal with things
like construction and demolition debris
but it would deal with a significant
amount of the waste coming into the
state which is coming from
municipalities primarily in
massachusetts
representative bixby
thank you thank you for taking my
question i just want to follow up on
that a little bit which is
i i want to make sure that it's clear
that this bill does not actually put
that requirement of the solid waste plan
on
um
municipalities beyond new hampshire that
this is just having the swag look at
that possibility and examine how
to do it or whether to do it yes that is
exactly correct um it will just be
evaluating whether this type of
prohibition is a smart move for new
hampshire it's up to the swag to make a
recommendation to the legislature after
they evaluate it but i think it's an
important thing to look at given the
amount of out-of-state waste that's
coming into new hampshire and
importantly the fact that there is now
going to be a forthcoming solid waste
management plan the current municipal
plans that new hampshire has their
municipalities create are supposed to
meet the goals and objectives of that
plan so it's really the perfect time to
begin evaluating this and they can make
the recommendation whether it's the
right move for new hampshire and that'll
be up for the legislature to decide at a
later date thank you
any further questions
seeing none we thank you thank you
anybody else that would like to speak on
this bill
all right see none uh the blue sheet we
have excuse me we have four sign ins in
person and online we have 50 in support
and one opposition
and with that i'm going to close the
hearing on sb 380.
uh
i don't think there's any opportunities
i just let me just start with you know
any any
anybody see any reason not to protect
this now
that's righty
all right
i think we're good all right we're going
to open up the exec session on senate
bill 380 and i will look to
representative bixby for a motion
i don't know i just decided it was oh
representative dutsy i'm sorry
uh mr chair i would like to
move for otp on senate bill 380-fn
all right do we have a second
representative stapleton seconds
so we have a motion to about to pass on
senate bill 380 and second i'll open it
up to the committee for discussion
representative dutsy would you like to
speak to your motion
um
yes i mean i i think this is a good idea
to give um
the swag jurisdiction over this so that
they can um explore it further and see
if any um regulations or legislation
needs to be considered
one of the things that i i want to say
and this is in relationship to nashua
nashua has its own landfill
and yet what we're finding
recently
is that we have um
enterprises that are coming in for
the reset
the
trashing i i'll say of commission of
construction and demolition debris
and what they're doing is they're using
false addresses
so they're saying that they're coming
here
for a certain address that they've been
[Music]
renovating their kitchen or their
bathroom and when
dpw goes ahead and checks it out and
calls that home that home has had no
renovations
so i think it's really critical that we
that we have the swag committee begin to
look at things like this because i think
with the pressures going on with
landfills you're going to find this
behavior
more and more within new hampshire so i
would hope that we would pass this
any further comment from the committee
seeing none i'm going to
ask the clerk to call the rule on senate
bill 380. we have a motion of ought to
pass
representative aaron
yes representative commtois yes
representative davis
representative stapleton yes represent
hamola yes represent mason
representative sanborn
represent bixby yes
representative suffocatus yes
represent dutsy yes
representative murray is not here
representative yes
representative perez
yes
mr chair yes
what
thirteen
one two three
to zero
all right with 13 to zero vote the
motion passes and without objection i'll
put it on the consent calendar
is representative
representative dussey you'll do the
majority report
thank you
all right and with that we're going to
be in recess until 1 pm
we will reconvene with the hearing of
senate bill
368 i believe too many yes senate bill
368 at 1pm
okay
uh
all right good afternoon everybody it is
now being one o'clock actually 102
i'm going to call the ena committee back
into
order and we will call on representative
bixby to introduce senate bill 368 in
the absence of senator bradley
good afternoon
it's a pleasure to be in ena
it's pleasure to have you representative
and
am here to introduce senate bill 368 fn
relative to the unlicensed sale of live
animals and establishing the
agricultural hearings officer revolving
fund
and
the person who knows the most about this
bill is sitting me sitting behind me
that would be the commissioner of
agriculture so i will let him take over
from here thank you representative
so we will call uh
commissioner jasper to up next to
testify and thank you commissioner good
to see you again welcome to ena
it's a pleasure to be here
um
thank you i am sean jasper commissioner
of the department of agriculture
368 was
introduced by senator bradley on
the department's behalf
after the senate hearing it it became
very clear to me that my original
concept
had some
some issues with it
that should be addressed and so
taking some time to
to look at what it really was that we
could best
uh accomplish
drafted
the amendment that you now see as the
senate senate bill
and
it was quite taken back actually by an
email that i received
yesterday which i believe you all
received
sunday i think it was a total
misrepresentation of
of the situation so
i do did give your clerk some written uh
written testimony and i'll try to stick
to that at this point
and i sent you all information that
covered some but not all of the points
uh in the email you received i didn't
have enough time to address everything
last night nor could i even absorb all
of the misstatements included at that
time
let me tell you about the reality of
what we face with unlicensed pet vendors
and while there may not be many of them
they take up an inordinate amount of
staff time
we have one business which which has
never been licensed and can't be due to
town zoning issues
we have a
drawer and a filing cabinet
dedicated to these people the files go
back more than 15 years
there have been several court cases but
even when the town wins the activities
persist
currently arrests have been made and
court dates have been set but the
transfer of dogs continues
if a person is willing to continue his
act as an unlicensed pet vendor and are
selling dogs for around
four thousand dollars each do you see a
thousand dollar fine as a disincentive
the reality is that only recently have
we been able to obtain the health
certificates that prove the violations
of law
this past year alone
around 200 dogs were transferred
illegally from this one
vendor
every hour that is spent on this case is
an hour not spent doing the job you have
asked us to do
this past year between working with the
local pd and tracking down health
certificates
we spent well over a hundred man hours
on this one case alone think about that
almost three weeks of one person's time
with no results even though one
individual has been arrested twice
the sale of dogs has not stopped
most of our issues are actually relative
to a few licensed facilities not meeting
the standards set out in our rules basic
conditions that the vast majority of our
licensees can and do meet
our goal is to bring them into
compliance not to revoke a license or
find them
in the four and a half years i've been
commissioner i believe that we have
revoked one license with one revocation
being adjudicated now
while the b the bill does increase fees
for repeated violations more importantly
it would allow us to deal with them in a
timely manner
ultimately it would free up time to do
the inspections which the legislature
has tasked us
with
the revocation that we are currently
dealing with has its roots in continuing
violations which began years ago
finally after years of non-compliance we
worked out a settlement agreement that
spelled out some very specific actions
which needed to be taken
the settlement agreement was not adhered
to and the license was revoked
but revocation does not prevent a person
to continue to operate until the case is
adjudicated
the lawyer for the licensee asked me if
that is really one of what i wanted to
see happen
the issue being that these were all
animal welfare violations
this individual could continue in
business without violating the law as
long as they transferred fewer than 30
dogs a year
at 4 dollars
a dog
that would mean they could have an
income
of about a hundred and sixteen thousand
dollars without being licensed and we
would have no right to inspect the
facility which is based in the owner's
home
so that's not a desirable situation
either
we are again in negotiations to ensure
the best outcome for the dogs but this
has been dragging on for months due to
other pressing issues such as avian
influenza
this is just one example of why we need
to free up staff time through the use of
an unbiased
contract hearings officer now i'm going
to add lib here for for a minute i
neglected to put this part in currently
we do all the hearings in-house
all-ish fines are issued under my
authority
however i sometimes as the rules allow
act as the hearing officer but it's
other times and i've said this in the
email a director that will ask act in
that place can you think of a more
biased situation than that where
co-workers i'm their
actual supervisor
and then i'm issuing fines well i think
the fact of the matter is if you look at
the fine letters and how we adjudicate
it we do a fair job but on the surface
no one would design a system that worked
that way
we can get into more issues in a work
session but i felt it was important to
put a few of these issues on the public
record in closing that i will say that
the email you received is probably the
most inaccurate communication that i
have ever seen sent to a committee
what is truly important in this bill is
the ability to contract within partial
hearing officers the issue of the fine
is much less important the history of
the department is that we seldom if ever
issue for fines for the maximum allowed
by law however we do believe that there
should be an increase in the fine for
repeatedly transferring animals above
the limit
thank you for your time and i'm happy to
answer any questions you might have
thank you commissioner uh representative
aaron
thank you mr chair and thank you
commissioner for coming and speaking on
this bill today
i'm interested just
to refer these
violations to the ag's office for
enforcement i did did address that
yesterday in in the email the age office
consumer protection
does not have the staff time to deal
with these type of things they have so
many the leadership in in doj has said
to their staff
we can't deal with this these are left
to the local
uh pd
and this is two separate tracks by the
way so don't confuse it's not an either
or
the violation is a misdemeanor that can
be adjudicated the fine is in addition
to
the misdemeanor
one we have absolutely no control on i
cannot force the local pd the county
attorney or the dog j to do anything
although any of those three entities
could
they seldom do the only enforcement that
we have as a department is through the
licensing and fining process
then could the legislature direct the
ag's office to handle those cases
you know i i if you want to give them
more staff i think you would
hear that they're backed up i mean we've
we're dealing with this one that has
been going on now for well over a year
there just isn't the time out there
and i'm not sure that anybody is ever
going to be put in jail
for transferring pets so then where do
you end up you end up in the same exact
spot
even though they you know a misdemeanor
is what traditionally a thousand dollar
fine or a year in jail
um they're not going to go to jail no
prosecutor is going to ask to send
somebody to jail for selling a dog that
i can see and we're left back in the
same spot
representative bixby
yes thank you for taking my question
uh one um
one issue that was brought up was that
uh so the it's a thousand dollars for
the first offense and it is five
thousand dollars for subs subs subscribe
to expen let me let me finish the
question so
i know that under cr uh in criminal
cases
uh if there are multiple offenses that
occur at the same time
like uh with the case in wolfeboro where
there were 75 uh negligent cruelty cases
all of those cases were considered a
first offense so in this situation is
the fir if if someone sells
uh
10 dogs and
those are and those are are all at the
same time would those be considered all
the first off for our first offense or
would that be one
thousand dollar offense plus
nine five thousand dollar offenses
it's up to first of all in even though
we have up to a thousand now i've never
seen a case where we have issued
the maximum
allowed but i will say that unlike if we
went in and did a uh an inspection of a
facility i think
a
convincing argument could be made that
all of those
uh violations that might be
found in an inspection would be a first
offense punishable only up to a thousand
dollars
in the case of dogs they're not
transferred
in mass
so i don't know that we see very often
that 10 dogs are transferred to one
person these are based on health
certificates so each health certificate
issued
is a violation
so while i don't think we would go from
one thousand
you know to five thousand for the second
third fourth and fifth we could but
those are clearly separate violations
because they're separate transfers
just like you don't get to get stopped
for speeding
in one town
and then get stopped 10 minutes later
for speeding
um and say hey i've just been fine for
for speeding 10 minutes ago
you know they're separate violations for
for separate acts thank you
representative murray
thank you mr chair for taking my
question thank you commissioner um one
question i do have for you and maybe you
can help me with this is it sounds like
what you were explaining to me is that
you are in fact
your department is in charge of hearing
this and then imposing the find my
question to you is i know that in fish
and game for example they have officers
who oftentimes impose those fines or
write a citation so to your knowledge
does any other department
operate the way you're describing it to
us not that i've ever heard of and let
me be clear what would continue is that
my
personnel
would go out they would do the
inspections they would write the letters
they would issue the fine
then it would stop it would go to a
hearing officer who would then schedule
that would here they would not be able
to issue additional fines they would not
be able to increase the fines all they
would be able to do
is potentially uphold the fines that
were issued by the personnel or reduce
them in most cases we do reduce the
fines
there was one
case where i recently was the hearing
officer where we tried very hard
to have a negotiated settlement and
reduce the fine and that person would
not agree to the fine so i upheld the
fine they they paid the original one but
in all the other cases
there has been probable there have been
section portions of the fines that i
have suspended
pending good behavior but that's what
the hearing officer would do and so
there's a very clear and bright line
they would have no relationship with the
uh with the department other than
contractual
and um
you know i think it's a much better you
know you know
a a fairer system than what we're we're
doing now i've never been comfortable
what we're doing but that's what's laid
out for us and that's all that's
available to us
thank you
representative compta
thank you mr chair thank you
commissioner for taking my question
um
so i'm a little confused um as to what's
going on with this particular vendor um
they're getting health certificates does
that mean the dogs are healthy is that
how we're tracking this person
they are getting they are getting health
certificates they're going to their
veterinarian dogs are being examined
health certificates are being issued the
veterinarian is doing nothing wrong has
no ability to say well you've already
transferred so many without a license
that's not his his thing his obligation
is when we ask him because we're still
working on the
um the database that was approved
um and that request for information has
gone out we are working there but we're
still a long way away so we now
we can't get
all of we can't deal with all of the
health certificates but when we become
aware of a problem like this we make the
request to the veterinarians in the area
who we suspect may be issuing health
certificates and that's the only way we
can figure out if somebody is in
violation other than that we really
don't have any way of knowing
recently
i did get a call or an email from a
police department who became aware of
people
transferring animals without health
certificates
now here's the interesting thing in law
which would probably be something i'll
ask you to look at next year
is it is a violation
to transfer animals without a health
certificate but there is no penalty for
doing so
so you don't actually have to have a
health certificate and you know i can't
stop anybody from doing that all i can
it's a violation and if they don't care
they're violating the law then nobody in
the state can do anything about it
follow
thank you mr chair thank you
commissioner
so
i'm trying to wrap my head around this
one so they're getting a health
certificate which means the veterinarian
is deeming that these puppies
or dogs are healthy
but the problem that you're saying is
that they're transferring more than 30
dogs
the in some cases yes the legislature
has set the limit to say what a pet
vendor was it used to be 50
brought it down to 25 brought it back to
30. that's a legislative decision
legislature has said that in order
if you meet that criteria you're a pet
vendor and then you come under licensure
and inspection
of of the facilities but we have people
that are
you know not becoming licensed and they
are not their facilities are not subject
to inspection now
you have to be clear that there are two
different things here a dog can be
healthy
and still be filthy and can be brought
up in filthy conditions
and improper
they're free of disease that's all it
really means
when they have a health certificate not
that they're well cared for or anything
else
and the legislature has determined that
at this limit we want these
these criteria met
now i will tell you if you know if you
don't have a problem with that everyone
in the department of agriculture would
be thrilled if you just did away with a
pet vending statue
you know this isn't something i want
this isn't something my veterinarians
want or anything this is
the biggest problem
other than avian influenza at the moment
that the department faces day in and day
out
and we have to do something this is an
incredible waste of
services i think the state of maine
has a staff of almost 30 people
doing nothing but dealing with pet
vending i have received one dedicated
person for pet funding
paul
thank you mr chair thank you
commissioner for that explanation
so basically what you're saying is that
this particular case that you have a
drawer full
of paperwork it's not because they're
not getting the transfer papers and the
health certificate it's because of the
living conditions of the puppies
no no what i'm saying is they have
they can't be licensed by their town
because they do not live in a zone that
allows them to
have a
kennel
and so they just continue to do what
they want to do and thus far
there really has been nothing that
anybody has been able to do about it now
they are facing court case i don't want
you to think this is the only one and
the only
i mean
this is the most extreme case
but it takes up a lot of time it's been
ongoing for 15 years and there are
others we are just at our wit's end
about what to do because we're not able
to do the inspections on all the license
facilities in the manner that we should
be because of the times that are taking
up
we are are simply in failure
when it comes to pet vending we have
been in failure when it was 50.
we are more in failure now
and i'm just saying
please don't ask us to continue to
operate in failure i'm not asking for
more money
i'm not asking for more people
i'm asking to allow us to use a portion
of that fine money
to be able to hire people who can then
free up a substantial amount of time it
takes hours and hours and hours to deal
with each hearing that we have
so this is about those hearings but
you know there are just so many moving
parts we are in failure
and i have a solution that costs you
nothing
now will it possibly take some money out
of the general fund potentially could it
add more there potentially but let's
face it we were what 60 million above
um estimates last month
and we're talking about maybe worst case
scenario
you know 80 90 000 and i don't see that
there's any way i'm going to have
contracts
anywhere near that amount
frankly but
you know you've put us in
you being the legislature have put us in
an impossible situation
i want out one way or another either
with a solution or just say hey we don't
care who pat transfers animals and how
they do it
so a couple of things that come to my
mind if this is a zoning issue has their
town taken any administrative action on
their part as far as issuing a cease and
desist absolutely they've gone to court
they've you know
it's you know they've been there
and arrested her twice
she's been arrested twice
yeah
so i'm
change that that's just one that's just
one example don't think right if that
one person went away that would solve
all our problems we'll change the topic
of hair to the fiscal note and um look
into that just a little bit so
i i was a little confused when i first
read the fiscal note and perhaps you can
just give a little clarity so it appears
what you're looking for is to use
current fines that you already rece the
department is already receiving from
areas other than the animal department
and you just want to allow the fines
that come from
this to be included with those other
fines to go to hiring this contracted
position am i understanding correctly
you are and thank you for that question
chairman pearl um and i should have
clarified that a little bit so weights
and measures actually brings in a lot
more fine money
than
animal industry
specifically pet vending
but we primarily the the
areas where we see fines are primarily
in weights and measures
in an animal industry
very little in in any of the other
divisions some in plant industry
most of those don't result in hearings
most of those are resolved through
negotiations before they ever get to a
hearing
um
and so when when you're told oh animal
industry is going to be supporting or
pet vendors are going to be supporting
hearings for others that's simply not
true the the person has no idea how how
we operate
um
but the pet vending part of it is the
most contentious even though we bring in
more money in in other areas those
people okay i get it they pay their fine
they move on
and this
is where we get into the really bogged
down
areas
thank you
representative aaron thank you mr chair
and thank you uh commissioner for taking
my question
so
i guess i'm a little
i'm not familiar with this so i'm a
little confused about i mean we have all
four divisions the animal industry
pesticide control regulatory services
weights and measures they all
generate administrative fines
is are all of those administrative fines
placed in one fund
they would be right now they are simply
when the money comes in it goes to the
general fund
okay so there are you know
multiple more than four divisions but
generally regulatory and pesticides
don't end up with a lot of
um fining it's really
the three divisions that tend to have
some some fine money coming in the bulk
of this coming from wages so a follow-up
question would be wouldn't it be better
to change the way in which
we're collecting those fines make those
fines perhaps
raise the fines across the board for all
of those
and then
that would help
perhaps fund more
the issue and cost of of these hearing
officers for any of no no well no
because currently and and i don't like
the idea of find money staying within a
department and so this doesn't
really because it's going whatever we
need is only being expended to hire the
hearing officers you know i think we're
all familiar with how
georgia
funds their their towns you know you get
a speed trap and that money stays in
coffers new hampshire doesn't operate
that way i also don't think i need a
full-time hearing officer so i don't
want to ask for a position i also see
that as somewhat of a conflict because
that person is still going to work for
me
and be responsible to me a hearing
officer is a contracted relationship
and
doesn't have that same relationship with
me or a division head or any anybody
else and it's only as needed
and so we don't need to raise the fines
other places the only you know and i
don't care if you raise don't raise the
fines
particularly if you want to rewrite the
bill and on anything to do with the
facilities you don't raid the raise the
fine the problem is as long as you can
sell a dog for four thousand dollars and
only be fined a thousand dollars
i'll do that all day long i don't know
about you
but if if i don't have to have
inspections i don't have to be licensed
and i can still have that three thousand
dollar profit per animal
that's a pretty good deal
and that's why that part of it needs to
be a disincentive so that people will
want to come in compliance with the law
that not i have passed but
you have passed
all right so for the benefit of the
committee here i i know there's many
more questions and there's there's
certainly some work that we're going to
need to do on this bill
i'm going to uh i'm going to ask that
the committee hold the rest of their
questions and i'm until next tuesday and
i'm going to schedule a work session on
this because we are going to run out of
time and we have some bills today that i
have to act on on exec committee
a procedural point on
turn your mic a procedural point uh i
think rather than scheduling a work
session it probably is procedurally
appropriate to can schedule a
continuation of the hearing
well we could do that but i think
honestly with our own agreement we've
got a little bit of work that we need to
do on this um
we can we can decide which way
procedurally is better but we'll we'll
definitely need to do some more on this
okay i would just consult with paul
about what that and
i will do that today about the
distinction between a work session so
i'll just consult with paul to make sure
that it gets scheduled appropriately
with house rules i will do that thank
you i appreciate that
all right commissioner we're going to
let you go for now and um we've got one
more card and then we're going to have
to go into an exact session here within
about the next five minutes so
i'll call on angela ferrari from the dog
owners of the granite state
all right sure you can just leave them
there and we'll pass them around
and i'll try and
keep this short in the interest of
everybody's time and there was a lot of
questions raised that
um i have as well
one thing and angela ferrari dog owners
of the granite state thank you very much
for your time today
um
one thing i just want to hit on that was
most recently discussed by the
commissioner was
for those who may be selling a dog for
four thousand dollars
minus a one thousand dollar fee does not
equal three thousand dollars profit and
they're happy
raising dogs breeding them everything
the care that goes into them is a very
expensive
line of work
and is it is not just all profit so a 1
000 fee would definitely be detrimental
to most breeders who are even able to
sell their dogs at that cost
one other thing i wanted to
bring up was that in discussions
previously with the commissioner he had
mentioned that fines were typically not
being paid and were being ignored at the
current rate that they even are so i
thought it was a bit curious that the
direction of this bill as it has been
amended is to just increase the fines
i'm not sure that we would actually see
compliance come out of that since the
issues that have been at hand are those
who are
having a blatant disregard for the
requirements to get licensed or legally
sell animals in new hampshire
also as mentioned by representative
bixby regarding the violations and what
would be a subsequent violation
we do read the bill that
an initial transfer of a puppy would be
the one thousand dollar fine and any
subsequent puppy transfer would
allow up to five thousand dollars per
transfer
and for a litter of ten puppies for
example as mentioned by representative
bixby that could be up to forty six
thousand dollars just in fines alone
what i see as a unintended consequence
of the increase in these fines is the
avoidance of transferring puppies to
avoid these fines
to avoid having to pay that 46 thousand
dollars
we actually believe that this could
promote hoarding when we look back at
the
bradford golden retriever case that we
saw in the last few years
the woman had lost had let her license
laps because she wasn't going over the
limit at the time when she went to get
her license reinstated
her town wouldn't let her due to zoning
and she was not able to transfer dogs
because
it would be illegal she would be due to
pay the fines she could get a
misdemeanor all of the things
and so she opted not to transfer the
puppies while she continued to try and
get her town to
allow her the ability to get a license
this went on for upwards of a year those
puppies got older they ended up breeding
amongst each other and she had more
puppies that she was unable to transfer
this was to try and avoid breaking the
law
that's in place currently with the
addition of higher fines i think we
would see that as more likely of an
issue we may see hoarding increase
another concern here is the conflict of
interest with the increased fines and
the
contracted hearing officers
in order for the hearing officers to be
funded
and for the department to be able to use
them and pay out monies to them
it would increase the likelihood that
the fines that were imposed on people
would be at the higher end to ensure
that there would be monies in the
revolving fund for these hearing
officers
talking about some solutions
we know that law enforcement is
responsible to prosecute pet vendors and
they're not making it a priority it
seems like the issue needs to be
addressed with law enforcement why they
aren't taking on this role that they
should be
if law enforcement wasn't interested in
dealing with driver speeding would we
just increase the price and fines for
speeding to deter people from speeding
most likely
we wouldn't do that but that's what it
feels like we're doing here rather than
addressing the actual problem
one thing that we came across is in the
pawn broker and money lenders
chapter 399 d they have the ability to
issue a cease and desist and with that
cease and desist the subject would be
able to be fined up to ten thousand
dollars or be imprisoned
i think that that might actually be more
of a deterrent than just saying for each
puppy you sell we're going to increase
the fines
and have the department potentially want
to go on the higher end of those fines
to fund hearing officers
so i would like to request that the bill
be inexpedient to legislate or refer to
interim study because i think there's a
lot of questions that are still open i
don't think that we're solving the issue
at hand and if we could have the time to
work together
dog owners of the granite state has
always offered to work on any of the
bills that impact our community
and we would really appreciate if the
commissioner or any others would reach
out to us to come up with a viable
solution and i would be happy to take
any questions
thank you
i i think in the interest of time we're
going to hold off on questions right now
and i think i will take the advice of my
fine friend from sitting two seats down
and and just we're going to recess this
hearing and we're going to continue it
to next tuesday at 2 p.m
and we'll do that and if there's further
uh important questions and in the
interim we'll probably work on
scheduling a work session as well
potentially after that i'll check on the
viability of that as well but for the
benefit of the committee there's clearly
more work that needs to be done here
so we'll we'll recess this hearing until
2 p.m next tuesday
and uh
i'm gonna go out on a limb and say we
can have this room but i have to check
and make sure on the scheduling but it
will be here someplace we'll find a room
but i believe it i'll work to get it
here
so we're going to do that and so that we
can act on the
exec the bills that we need to before 2
pm today
and then we have some early bills so so
i'm going to recess this hearing now
until 2 pm next tuesday
the only thing i forgot to well i guess
i don't need to read the blue sheet
we'll do that next week
okay i'm gonna
give the clerk a minute to catch up
before we go into exec section here
no
it feels good
forgive me
there's a new one coming out
um
okay
so representatives
we're going to open the executive
session and we'll be executing senate
bill 267 and i'm going to recognize
representative bixby for a motion
you might would you might gunner
all right
i move that we uh
adopt amendment
uh
to uh 2022-1441h
to sb 267 and
uh then
vote the bill
as amended ought to pass so
representative bixby moves out to pass
an offer on 267 and offers amendment
2022-14418 do i have a second and i
actually i will second that okay and
i'll recognize representative bixby to
speak to his motion okay so um
the uh we recognized that uh
the letter h of the bill as uh as it
came over to us from the senate uh would
have uh
could be read as requiring the
participation of a set of
uh
bodies that we don't have authority over
um
and uh that uh the
coordinator uh is the intent of this of
this uh line was to
have the coordinator
offer
uh to have other agencies and
municipalities universities general
public et cetera
participate so
i
amended it to read invite the
participation of
and
then pretty much the same list of bodies
that were that were in the
bill as presented to us by the senate
there was some question about whether it
made sense to have
environmental non-governmental
organizations listed among those and
the prime sponsor suggested that it
would be
cleaner if we did not have that because
it would um
taking it out would reduce the
possibility of perceiving this is is as
political anyway and i don't see a
problem with that so
i am
moving this amendment that removes the
reference to environmental
non-governmental organizations and uh
phrasing it as particip inviting
participation rather than requiring
coordination
i i want to thank representative bixby
for
taking into the concerns that were
raised in providing a good clean
amendment that should address all of the
concerns is there any further discussion
from other members of the committee
regarding the amendments
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the rule on the amendment this
will be ought to pass are
amending the house senate bill 267 with
amendment 2022-14418
okay
representative aaron yes
represent
yes representative simon
yes representative davis yes
representative stapleton yes
representative pamola yes represent
johnson yes represent mason yes
representative sambon yes representative
bixby yes
representative spang
representative dutsy yes representative
murray yeah
represent vonsky yes
represent kaplan yes
represent perez
yes mr chair yes 17-0
we've adopted the amendment so the
amendment passes 17-0 and i will
so representative bixby i will recognize
you to speak to you ought to pass as
amended motion on
senate bill 267a yes
i don't know that we need a whole lot
more discussion um i think that uh
it's clear that this bill will be useful
in helping
the department and the state deal more
effectively with invasive species in
upland invasive species
so
i move ought to pass with amendment
two to as 2022-14418
i had i had previously seconded sorry i
guess i got ahead of myself in
recognizing but
is there any further discussion from the
committee
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on senate bill 267 fna otpa
with amendment 2022-1441
h
representative aaron
yes representative contra yes
representative simon yes representative
davis yes representative stapleton yes
represent pamola
yes
represent johnson yes represent mason
yes represent sanborn
represent bixby yes representative um
spang
represent dutsy
represent murray yes represent von
plinsky yes represent kaplan yes
represent perez
yes
mr chair yes 17-0
motion hey motion passes and we've
adopted the otpa
because we have such a high fiscal note
we're not able to put this on consent i
don't believe and so i believe it's
going to have to go on the regular
calendar and representative bixby will
be doing the committee report
thank you
yes
i just have to have it in by
if you can get it to me tomorrow we
should be fine preferably by before noon
okay thank you
when the clerk is ready we'll move on to
we're going to be accepting uh senate
bill 379 next but i'm going to go to the
clerk i'm almost she's ready all right
clerk is ready
all right so we're going to uh
open the executive session on senate
bill 379
a establishing the solid waste
management fund and grant program and i
will recognize representative murray for
a motion
yes thank you mr chair i'd like to make
the motion of ought to pass um with
regard thank you
and uh representative aaron did you want
a second yes
yes i'd be happy to second all right we
have a motion about to pass on senate
bill 379 about to pass and i will
recognize
representative murray to speak to her
motion thank you mr chair sorry fir
so yes as we heard the hearing this
morning i believe that this is
definitely a step in the right direction
with regard to solid waste management
fund
the department of environmental services
is one of the only 100 like 100
generally funded departments and i see
this as necessary to continue to do the
work that we need to do with regard to
solid waste and recycling within the
state so thank you any further
discussion by the committee
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the role on the motion about to pass on
senate bill 379
representative aaron
yes represent commtois yes represent
simon yes represent davis yes
representative stapleton yes represent
pamula yes
represent johnson yes represent mason
yes represent sam boyne yes
represent bixby yes representative spang
represent duty yes represent murray yes
represent vamplinsky yes represent
kaplan yes represent perez yes mr chair
yes 17-0 with a vote of 17-0 we've moved
out to pass and without objection i'll
put this on the consent calendar
okay xenon
so we'll close the exec session on
and i'm sorry
yep representative murray will be
writing that report by tomorrow noon
thank you
and with that we'll close the exec
session on that and open up the exec
session on senate bill 396
when the clerk is ready
you all set i'm open yeah all right the
clerk is ready she's way ahead of me
today
okay and i'm going to
move
ought to pass on senate bill 396 and i'm
looking for a second
representative kaplan will second
excuse me pon polinski
you don't but i
i looked at you and read his name and
sorry my apologies
representative von plinsky seconds
representative kaplan's just happy to be
here with us right
as we all are
i'll recognize myself to
speak to this motion so this was a bill
that we heard last week and there was
only the prime sponsor that spoke in
favor of the bill and
this allows des to
contract and bill out services when it's
looking for
creating reports
relating to i'm trying to get the term
sorry hydrology i believe and i can't
seem to read it fast enough but
this uh this bill seemed to make sense
and had the full support of des so i
would ask the committee to support or
not to pass motion
i'll open up for further discussion
representative bixby yeah so um just to
uh encapsulate what
so if
the
if des uh is in the program is in a
permitting process and they feel that
they need an independent hydrogeologist
to
uh assess
some aspect of the prod project they can
hire that
independent hydrogeologist and require
the applicant to pay the pay for the
services so it's a pretty much a
housekeeping type bill thank you
representative that was the word i was
looking for and i couldn't get my eye on
it
any further comments
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the role on uh senate bill 396 with a
motion about to pass
representative barron yes
representative contra
yes representative simon yes represent
davis yes representative stapleton yes
represent pamola yes represent johnson
yes represent mason yes represent
sanborn
represent bixby yes representative spang
dutsy
represent murray yes represent von
plinsky yes represent kaplan yes
represent perez yes mr chair yes 17-0
well the vote of 17-0 the committee
moves the ought to pass recommendation
and without objection i'll put it on the
consent calendar
okay that will close out the exact
session for today
and we have a
subcommittee
hearing or work on
senate bill
367 367 thank you i was looking for it
uh beginning at 2 pm and
again well remind the committee that i
will be reconvening next week i
anticipate we'll probably schedule
another work session at 1pm on 367 if
it's necessary
and that's why i moved the other hearing
until 2 p.m so that's my anticipation
but we'll we'll see what comes out of
today's work session and what the needs
are but i would ask the committee
members to keep that open if if it's
necessary
thank you all and
i'll turn the gavel over again to
representative murray at 2pm
yes
it's crazy
that's
peace
yes
seeing that the time is 201 i am going
to open the
subcommittee work session
for senate bill 360 celib 367 relative
to regulatory statuses of advanced
recycling and manufacturing facilities
so with that i will open the hearing
all right
good afternoon everyone
um
i just a brief reminder today that as we
are proceeding and asking questions that
we have that we make sure that we are
being mindful of the process of
as we're going back and forth between
those who may be pros and cons it's a
fairly informal process so for those of
you coming before us please make sure
you turn on your microphone and announce
yourself and who you are with or where
you are from so with that i will
open the
floor to any of the
subcommittee work members who have
questions
oh you're right
i'll recognize representative contra
first
thank you and i'm not sure if anybody in
the audience can answer this
my question is regarding the energy that
it would take to run a facility like
this
oh i'm sorry it's it's this gentleman
here
yeah sorry
i didn't see it i was apologizing i
didn't see it a badge so
on here good afternoon
how's everybody doing today
good just uh i'm craig cookson i'm the
senior director of plastic
sustainability with the american
chemistry council in washington dc
but happy to be here today get to the
question a second i'm actually a native
of keene new hampshire i grew up there
i'm a keen high blackbird my father
worked at a company called kingsbury
corporation
for 27 years well-known employer in
southwest new hampshire for over 100
years
and my mother worked at keene state
college so it's great to be always great
to be back in new hampshire so
so as your question
let me talk a little bit about the
process so the most common technology
used in advanced recycling is known as
pyrolysis and pyrolysis is there's no
oxygen in the process so there's no
combustion so let me talk about what
kind of happens so plastics that have
been sorted from the solid waste stream
you know they've been sorted segregated
once twice maybe three times come into
the facility
excuse me
those plastics are usually shredded up
and maybe melted so they provide sort of
an even kind of flow into the system
then they are put into the system and
the system is heated using natural gas
um
just you know natural gas the same
natural gas that would go into your home
or to a business to provide you know
some some heat
and they're heated until they melt and
they continue to be heated until they
turn into gas vapors again there's no
combustion right and you cool and
condense those gas vapors back into
what's called a liquid feedstock and
that feedstock displaces
natural gas or oil used in the
production of new plastics and chemicals
again so it keeps that oil in the ground
keeps the plastics out of landfill
now
there is
a hundred percent of the plastics do not
become this liquid feedstock there's a
byproduct called char char is kind of
like an ash or basically it's carbon um
in kind of a powdered form
that can be they're looking at
opportunities to use it as carbon black
or an ink or you know tires things like
that and then the other fraction is
about 10 percent
are non-condensable gases so think of
propane uh that you you know
have a backyard grill or a backyard
barbecue with so they use those
non-condensable gases as process energy
for the system so that you don't need to
use any sort of new virgin natural gas
so once the system gets going it
actually kind of powers itself now
there's been a lot of different life
cycle analysis studies on this
technology that looks at the energy use
but that's basically the energy use
right it's just to provide
a heat source for the system but
a range of life cycle studies done by
basf
excuse me honeywell eastman um agilex
and others show that there is there are
reductions of greenhouse gas emissions
so there's lower energy use compared to
sort of conventional way that we both
manage our plastics which would be to
you know incinerate them or to landfill
them
or uh or in at the same time also
drilling for a new oil source right so
you have to kind of account for both
things the fact that one the plastics
are not going to landfill and not going
to incineration and number two you're
not having to drill for that additional
unit of oil so so yeah so this is a
a process that's going to help us get to
a lower carbon economy
so what you're saying uh and i was just
wondering about the energy
consumption at the plant more so than in
the the process um how much
well i guess if you're using natural gas
gas throughout the entire plant um what
are the btus that are being consumed
i would have to
get back to you on the exact amount of
b2s it's going to depend on the size of
the plant
uh representative homala hi thank you so
much i had a question um do you have a
percentage of what amount of char
is
produced in this process yeah so i would
think of it almost like an 80 10 10 type
of proposition you know give or take a
few percentage points
the 80 percent is the liquid
uh
product that you know goes and becomes
new plastics again
and you know
think about this way that's where these
facilities make their money is by
selling that product so they are
uniquely incented to maximize every last
molecule into the liquid feedstock about
about 10 percent become you know stays
as this non-condensable gas and used as
again process
energy for the system and then about 10
is char
i'm going to recognize myself for a
question if you don't mind um
so when we're talking about the char
that 10
right
um
we also see similar sort of
processes when we're talking about solid
waste management i know a little bit
about that so
um oftentimes that
that
method leaves a leachate cake or like
some sort of non-disposable thing that
then has to be disposed of elsewhere
what is happening to that 10 of char
what are you doing with it yeah that's a
good question so right now that char can
be safely landfilled again these
facilities want to maximize
every single thing they produce right
both their products and any sort of
byproducts or co-products so they are
currently looking how that this
char can be used in other products again
like a carbon black um
but to your question
you know just as any manufacturer has
kind of a byproduct and then that is
governed by rikra
and your you know state
um
you know solid waste statute so any
waste that's produced is governed under
your solid waste statutes right they
have to be in compliance so this is all
fully regulated this is you know again
has to be regulated under the resource
conservation recovery act
thank you
thank you madam chair and thank you
again for the question when it comes to
the char that's going to be disposed of
in the landfills
um knowing that it is a plastic
byproduct
uh
will it contain pfafs
no it won't um so first of all
the char is really just a carbon product
number one um so it's almost like
powdered carbon number two
is the facilities this is i i i think
where we have to um i think the most
important point to mention here as we
discuss these technologies really
separate
what this what these technologies are
from sort of your traditional solid
waste right where solid waste is
handling mixed garbage with no sort of
incoming specification right and the
facilities that get garbage are being
paid to take it off people's hands
because it has no value in the
marketplace
the big difference here is this is a
very
you know
high-tech process so number one the
facilities are going to be managing
their inbound feedstock so they're going
to be
working with their suppliers of the
plastics to make sure that they don't
have contaminants or if they have any
contaminants they're very very very very
low right because they don't want to
inherit somebody else's problem kind of
like a bakery a bakery is if someone
sends them a you know rotten eggs you
don't want to make cupcakes and brownies
out of those rotten eggs you're going to
send them back to that farm that they
came from right so the same thing here
is they're going to be managing the
plastics that are coming in because they
just want the carbon and hydrogen
molecules because that's what converts
to a liquid so number one there's
controls on the front end
excuse me on the back end this liquid
feedstock is replacing you know a sort
of a
a gas product you know natural gas
product or an oil product in billion
dollar um you know chemical and plastics
manufacturing plants so
they have to hit a very tight
specification to be accepted at those
facilities because you have billions of
dollars of infrastructure you know
in jeopardy they're not going to sort of
put those in jeopardy by and introducing
contaminants into the system so the
point being is there's a lot of
management on both ends right so you're
really managing your inbound feed stock
and you're managing the product that you
produce because you have to hit
specifications on both ends
thank you um i'm going to recognize
representative bixby um quickly um
oh did you have a follow-up
sorry representative let me let me get
her follow-up first please
sorry no worries thank you madam chair
and just to follow up you mentioned
suppliers of plastics
because we're concerned with our
landfills here in new hampshire
and um
if this was to be something we looked at
will the suppliers only be taking
plastic that is
in new hampshire or will they be
bringing in plastic from outside the
state
they could uh it depends right um i mean
i think we've included a provision in
the bill that they look first to new
hampshire suppliers of plastics and
again that could be commercial
businesses um i think a you know your
super stop and shop or your hannaford
brothers down the street they produce a
lot of plastic film and wrap
that's actually a really good material
for this a lot of that film actually
goes all the way on a truck all the way
down to uh virginia where it gets turned
into decking for treks but those markets
are not insatiable right so there's
opportunities for that type of material
then there's also the plastics in the
home that we don't recycle now we do a
good job of recycling our plastic
bottles our milk jugs our you know pets
soda and water bottles our detergent
bottles but think everything else our
frozen pea bag our deli containers our
coffee lids things like that those are
the types of plastics that these
facilities would be so they would work
with a variety of suppliers of plastics
i think is your question but there's
nothing in this bill that precludes them
from taking um
out of state plastics however we did put
in the bill uh a some language around
preference for in-state plastics because
you're right you do want to sort of
make sure that new hampshire residents
can recycle more and greater types of
plastics you representative bixby though
he is not a member of the subcommittee
he's a member of environment and
agriculture and therefore go ahead
so um
a little bit more in terms of uh the
sort of the process from feedstock
through separation so um
plastics
don't just contain polymers they also
contain a number of additives that are
used as plasticizers as colorants as um
you know
way
anti-static
films um num uh biocides
uh depending on the use of the plastic
and
uh those additives contain a range of
metals and
halides such as chlorine fluorine
bromine
what is the fate of
the
non-hydrocarbon
uh elements that are in the plastic that
goes in that's in the feed stock sure
i think
um it's a good question and i think the
first point i want to just kind of
reiterate the point is that uh the
companies are uniquely incentive to sort
of try to keep
you know anything that isn't plastic
right out however you're right there are
certain you know additives and things in
plastics um and so a lot of the
technologies do have processes in place
in the system where they can uh so both
sort of purify
the oil that they have um as well as
purify the gases um specific too i gotta
be careful here because you know certain
the technologies all have kind of
proprietary processes because being able
to hit the specification that the
plastic manufacturer wants is you know a
important business differentiator but a
lot of the companies will use like
sodium
to bind to any sort of fugitive chlorine
or fluorine that makes it in the system
and folks who know their chemistry
sodium chloride is assault right so
that's one technique that is used to
sort of remove any of these
types of things like halogenated types
of
compounds
and
and then there's also
there's also a very
sophisticated scrubbers on the back end
that sort of pull any sort of these
compounds out
okay
yeah so um
so do the
do the halides end up in the liquid
fraction and then get extracted that
that point with the uh with the sodium
or do they
um
or or do they
or is that extraction done in the
pyrolysis chamber at the 300 to 600
degrees celsius
it's it's normally
done during the pyrolysis process right
so you sort of form the salts there to
take those out a lot of these facilities
you know i i'll give you a sort of a
quote
excuse me sorry a little uh frog my
throat but
we have one member that is taking um
a sort of a product a feedstock product
from a supplier and their catalyst which
is a 50 million dollar catalyst
insured up to 50 million i should say
to continue to get that insurance they
have to ensure that anything they put
into their system has less than 10 parts
per billion of chlorine
so this is a system where these
companies are uniquely
uh set up to have to
do sort of the purification steps and
anything to avoid um
you know things downstream where the
ultimate customer will not take them so
again there's kind of several controls
here one is prevent it from coming in
the door in the first place so they're
gonna know where their feed stock is
coming from if it's coming in with
you know levels of chlorine that are
high they're going to send it back and
say we're not doing business with you
anymore
it's possible to keep 100 of everything
out so that's where the systems come in
place with with the scrubbers and making
sure that they you know sodium and other
um types of systems to
neutralize it
so would this mean that
they would not be able to accept
polyvinyl chloride pipe as a as
feedstock for
uh
for this process and
given and sort of as an analogy
analogous to that question
uh is there an entire range of plastics
that are just not susceptible to being
processed
in this way
yeah that's a good question
so
pvc kind of has its own
types of technologies the technologies
listed in this bill like pyrolysis
for instance
are going to be taking mostly
polyethylene polypropylene and
polystyrene because that's what's going
to yield the most product
technologies like methanolisis or
gasification can take plastics like this
p-e-t water bottle because there's
actually oxygen atoms in here and they
do a little bit of a different process
and form different types of
molecules and and precursor chemicals um
once they're done but uh
but so i would say if you're running a
pyrolysis unit i can actually say this
is that they are
very much likely not to be taking pvc
pipe
[Music]
thank you i'd like to also ask a
continuing democrat a couple more
questions around the condensation
process because we're talking about an
anoxic environment you mentioned that
then there is some sort of condensation
in that
are there other sorts of chemicals that
are trapped inside the condensate what's
going on inside that leftover water is
it being
off-gassed is it
leaving some other way are you
collecting it and then disposing of it
what's happening with that
so you're saying can you
and so my question is are there
contaminants stuck inside of that water
is that water being collected is it
going somewhere
water could be used as a sort of a
coolant right to sort of take the um the
gas vapors
back down to a liquid
but the technologies are really going to
try to avoid number one especially in a
pyrolysis system you're likely not to
have very many oxygen molecules
number two
the hydrogen molecules are the most
valuable thing that you can have right
as member was describing the system as
an 80 20 or 80 10 10 system you're kind
of left over with carbon right and
that's
in in the char and that's because
there's not enough hydrogen molecules to
it attached to so if you're producing
water
that's a problem with your efficiency
because you're losing as we all know
from you know basic chemistry h2o you're
losing two hydrogens so and there's
oxygen in the system so in a pyrolysis
system they're not going to produce
water
thank you additionally one of the other
things that i had wanted to kind of talk
about was that you had testified that
there
there would be no chance that there
would be any sort of contamination pfas
left over in the liquid version
of this material and so i guess what i'm
asking is
then we had uh representative bixby
talking about
metals non-ferrous and ferrous metals
are you testing the feedstock coming in
how is that source sorting is there like
a bill of lading that says yes this
stuff has been
inspected like what's going on there
so a lot of testing is going on right so
number one they're going to be testing
the
um
the inbound feed stock right to make
sure that it's hitting the specification
that they need to be able to produce a
good sort of oil product number two
the oil product is going to be tested
and tested a lot by the companies that
are then taking that and using it as an
alternative
material
the new hampshire des would come out and
do stack testing i was out at a company
called altera
energy out in uh akron ohio several
weeks ago you can it's right there on
linkedin and twitter and while we were
there the ohio epa was doing stack
testing that day so there will be
testing of that additionally
under you know rickra rules the char
would be tested to make sure that
there's no hazardous constituents in
that char
so there's a lot of testing going on
both from the government regulation
standpoint
as well as
you know sort of how you're running sort
of the most optimal business here which
is
make sure you have a good sort of
product coming in the door
and also that the product that are that
you're having a good sort of feed of
plastics coming in the door as well as
making sure that the product you are
sending out to the customer is going to
hit their spec
representative homeowner
thank you i just wondered could you give
us some examples of some states who are
further down the line and are
functioning with some of these advanced
recycling
ohio is a great example wonderful
company there called
altera
they are they have a
investment from a company called neste
neste is a big finish company
that is really moving towards more
circular types of products they do a lot
they actually just had an announcement
with mcdonald's
mcdonald's is piloting some uh cups down
in the savannah georgia area that are
made from both biogenic content as well
as content made from advanced recycling
so that's ohio ohio is one of the states
that have passed legislation very
similar to this
georgia is another great example this
company called nexus nexus is right now
taking plastics um as is altera the
plastics are coming in the door they're
turning it into this liquid feedstock
they send that feedstock to both shell
a chemical plant that they have in
louisiana as well as chevron phillips
based in in the texas area
nexus also has
some really good
investment partners
georgia is a state that passed this
legislation as well texas not
surprisingly is kind of a really
interesting state in that of course a
lot of the off take or the plastics
producers are there they passed very
similar legislation a couple years ago
companies like honeywell have
announced facilities there a company out
of uh the uk called plastic energy that
has two working facilities in spain
right now and we can get more into
plastic energy because they are the the
starting point for
recycled plastics that are in magnum
unilever ice cream tubs and mondelez
philadelphia cream cheese tubs are doing
some really fabulous things so texas is
another
success story um there is brave and
environmental in zebulun north carolina
they actually moved down
to north carolina from new york they
were kind of birthed in yonkers new york
but the regulatory environment a little
tough tougher there um but they're doing
some really exciting things they also
have off take with chevron phillips
chevron phillips by the way
important to say this as i've mentioned
them a few times they have a commitment
that by 2030 to produce one billion
pounds
of what they're calling their marlek's
circular polymers so those are polymers
that are made from recycled plastics not
from you know virgin oil or natural gas
so this is happening um eastman is
another fabulous company they're based
in kingsport tennessee tennessee has
also passed very similar to legislation
they have two technologies they have a
gasification technology that enables
them to take things like carpet which is
very difficult to recycle they also have
a methanolisis technology
they are working with warby parker
anybody have warby parker glasses here
um warby parker is uh
is you know using it's a you know a
different type of plastic and they are
you know recycling their glasses through
um eastman system and also working then
get recycled content into their glasses
through this system eastman also has a
partnership with
procter gamble and so the herbal essence
kind of five different types of their
conditioner and shampoo bottles are
going to be made with recycled plastics
thanks to
advanced recycling
and i think my favorite example is
wendy's the wendy's announced and this
is all you know
it's all on google we can provide all
these examples um you know following the
testimony wendy's announced several
months ago that they're moving from a
lined paper cup which was not recyclable
to a fully plastic cup made with 20
recycled plastics and again this is in
one thing i haven't said is all this is
certified by the international
sustainability and carbon certification
program iscc plus which means that
somebody goes to each step of the
process and says okay you got plastics
in okay you produce this liquid okay you
um sent this liquid to
uh you know chevron phillips or shell or
whoever and then they produced a plastic
and then that plastic went to you know
the in this case it's berry plastics
that makes uh the cup for wendy's so
yeah there's a lot of success stories
out there and again this is gonna i
think the most important thing is number
one
it's gonna enable us to recycle more
amounts and greater types of plastics
than we recycle now we really only
recycle our bottles very well
and it's also going to enable us to get
more recycled plastics into our um into
our packaging again because it's very
difficult to get mechanically recycled
plastics into food pharmaceutical and
medical contact packaging
do you find that in the places that are
doing this that they're having to sort
of change their consumer habits about
what goes into the recycling bins if
you're saying you know you've got water
bottles but other things
you know frozen
frozen food bags whatever does that is
that changing what does that look like
is the ripple effect yeah that's a good
question is that's kind of the the the
likely sort of demand pull you know um
as these facilities get more established
and grow and pull more plastics into the
system
that's kind of the next evolutionary
step is where people be able to put more
types of plastics i think a good example
of this in action
is the city of houston announced a you
know america's fourth largest city
houston announced a partnership with two
two of our companies lion delbasel and
exxon mobil they announced a um
a
a partnership with a
a waste hauler
called i think it's fcc and then also a
company called cyclix and what cyclix
does is prepare this feedstock by
aggregating the plastic and then
producing a feedstock that can be used
and so the nation's fourth largest city
is really working to draw more plastics
into the system so like your frozen pea
bag and your your coffee lid your pouch
of granola or beef jerky this stuff that
right now we're not putting in our
recycling bin so it's kind of exciting
so the key is to get the demand in place
first right because no one's going to
sort
plastics that they don't have a market
to sell to until there's that market to
sell to and then that's going to pull
along these plastics that right now
we're not putting in the bin
one more
and and i'm not this is a very basic
question and i don't know the answer so
i'm just gonna ask it
on the financial side of that
are people
paying that
advanced recycling facility money to
take their product or is that facility
paying them to take their product back
that's a great question because it's a
fundamental difference between
manufacturing and waste disposal right
waste disposal
you have something that is garbage and
it's worth nothing and so people you
have to pay somebody to take it off your
hands because you can't do anything with
it except burn it bury it
whereas
this process they pay for the plastics
because it's a commodity that has value
and so that value then it you know and
really the value starts all the way at
the end over 400 companies um globally
have committed big brand companies have
committed to having up to 30 recycled
content or recycled plastics in their
packaging
they're putting pressure on their
converters you know like the berry
plastics who makes the drink cup for
wendy's to provide them with those
plastics barry in turn is looking
upstream and saying to their suppliers i
need recycled plastics from you because
my customers are pushing me to get this
so those 400 companies um are really
providing a lot of demand pull right now
so there's a lot of value plastic prices
um as well just for your your water uh
bottles right now and your um things
like milk jugs and detergent balls are
at like really high prices now too
there's a huge there's a lot of demand
for um for you know this type of stuff
yep
thank you uh representative contra and
then i will go to representative kaplan
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
again for taking a question um i have
two
one has to do with the recyclable
products once
those say the wendy's recyclable cups
get into the system are they able to
come back into the facility to be
recycled again yes absolutely
that's that's one of the exciting things
about this is the lined paper cup
is a challenge to recycle but a fully
plastic cup that's going to be a
polypropylene cup which is very similar
to a deli container or you know big
yogurt container that can be recycled
yes
and my other question was
one thing that you said that kind of
raised a flag for me and um
right now there is really nothing in the
northeast area of any of these
facilities
but you made a mention that you moved
braven
move from new york to north carolina due
to the regulatory environment
so my question to you is is are you
looking at new hampshire because of our
regulatory environment
we are here
looking for
a you know a sort of
a system that will sort of support these
facilities right there's a real
opportunity in the northeast for this
technology um you know i would say the
closest facility there's just been an
announcement for a facility in
pennsylvania um
you know ohio is probably or north
carolina the closest sort of working
facilities
so this is an opportunity to in new
hampshire to allow the residents here to
recycle more types and greater amounts
of the plastics
but to do so the challenge is is when
these facilities i mean a lot of these
technologies or companies are more early
commercial
and it takes from the day of the
announcement it might take up to three
years to build a facility
and so the challenge is if they go in
and they're classified wrongly as solid
waste
it's going to be a number one kind of
time consuming to sort of talk about
okay this is what we're doing and six to
nine months later
the solid waste folks are going to say
okay whoops you know you should be down
the hall
getting the air permit and your your
water permit and other things from from
the manufacturing office
that's number one so because when you
when you
are looking to cite a facility it's kind
of four key things is one you gotta you
gotta find um a site right so you gotta
work within the local community i think
that's very important is sort of is
working with the local community just
because you might pass this law in new
hampshire doesn't sort of negate the
fact that companies are gonna going to
work with
local officials to find suitable
locations so that's number one right
number two
is they have to line up their feed stock
agreements okay who's got the plastics
and can they get the plastics to us in
the specification that we need it right
they're not going to be taking the pvc
pipe likely right so they have to line
that up number three they have to line
up their offtake partner so once we
produce our liquid who are we gonna sell
that to you know and what is their
specification and then number four
there's lining up investors or loans or
whatever to finance the facility so
having a transparent
um predictable regulatory system of the
types of permits that they need is very
important and we can get into it more
but regulating these facilities as
manufacturing also better protects the
public health because you're regulating
the things that these facilities
actually do
one more and then just so that we're
clear i i will go to re rep um
okay oh thank you and then i'd like to
actually ask a few questions from folks
yeah absolutely
i guess
i mean you gave a nice answer but the
question was
the regulatory environment in new
hampshire versus the surrounding states
is it is it why it's more attractive uh
to put try and push this legislation
through new hampshire
our
i would say
to answer that i would say we are
looking at there are other
bills in states right now so new york is
considering this legislation
they've had hearings on it rhode island
is considering this legislation
connecticut had a hearing on this
legislation so this is a legislation
that policy makers from across the
country there's 18 states that have
passed similar legislation and more
states that are considering it right now
including new hampshire uh michigan
there's actually a hearing on this today
so i would
i'm trying to think of how you want me
to answer this but the point being is
that this is something that um
is you know if you want to attract sort
of new business this types of business
this type of business that can help sort
of reduce your landfill or plastics go
into landfill and um in
waste energy plants
this is legislation is important because
it sort of
enables a predictable transparent
regulatory framework
thank you
i'm going to pause for a moment and i
have a few questions for the director
both director wimsat and i apologize to
the gentleman to your
right
yes if you two wouldn't mind answering
some questions around some of this line
of questioning i would wonder if you
would speak to them
sure
so thank you okay so one of the
questions that i did have you know
yes so if you could yes thank you yeah
thank you
absolutely
and feel yeah if there's a third chair
just arranger
department of environmental services
and then an additional air quality so
my name is mike fitzgerald i am the
assistant director of the air resources
division we are part of the department
of environmental services uh we're in a
separate division from the waste
division
and also as i mentioned with me is todd
moore todd is one of our senior
permitting managers uh within the air
division
um directors
uh so some of the things that we had
heard both today around one question i
did have was around this 10 percent of
the char that is sort of left over
and it is it was testified just
previously that it would then go into
the landfill do you know if that
potential char would be considered
hazardous waste would it be disposed of
in a separate area of a landfill what
does that look like to you to the best
of your knowledge sure i i have to
preface again mike wimsat director of
the waste division for new hampshire des
i preface my remarks by saying it's
going to be very specific to
the particular process and i will also
tell you we don't have much experience
really with these advanced recycling
facilities so what i'm going to
tell you comes from my broad experience
in dealing with solid and hazardous
waste but not based on any specific
knowledge of an advanced recycling
activity but generally speaking any
waste that's going to go to a solid
waste facility particularly from a
manufacturing facility
um has there's a requirement under state
law to do what's called a waste
determination so you're required to
understand what went into generating
your waste
evaluate that
if that indicates any appropriate need
for testing to ensure that there are you
know it to determine whether there are
any hazardous constituents
in concentrations that would render
something a hazardous waste or
characteristics then you're required to
do that and that's pretty routinely done
the landfills have
staff who are dedicated to working with
their commercial customers to make those
determinations
so um the expectation is that that would
be evaluated if it were a hazardous
waste it would not be accepted for
disposal at a solid waste facility and
would have to go off for shipping
specifically to a hazardous waste
facility that was permitted
if it were
eligible it was if it was classified as
a solid waste and not a hazardous waste
it could go to the landfill and likely i
mean landfills depending on the nature
of the mature their landfilling may make
their own decisions about where and how
they want to dispose of certain types of
waste but there would no would be no
specific requirement under state law to
dispose of it any differently than
other wastes that go into the landfill
thank you
representative kaplan
yes um
are you concerned at all that the epa
hasn't
issued any rulings on on these sort of
facilities and i mean because usually
you try to guide yourselves by what the
epa is doing in most cases is that
correct
sure so so there's really there's a
couple things going on here um basically
epa um does have very specific standards
associated associated with the design
and construction of what they call a
subtitle d facility which is a under the
resource conservation recovery act
subtitle d covers solid waste and they
have very specific requirements for how
if you're going to have an approved
program which new hampshire does how
those landfills are designed and
operated and in our rules for for
governing those landfills um
are are consistent with that and
actually exceed the ex exceed the
requirements in many respects of what's
required at the federal level
but as far as them looking at the
specific activity i think that is more
focused on air emissions issues than it
is waste disposal so i haven't really
familiarized myself with that debate
that's going on right now and perhaps
mike or todd could answer that
so
from an air perspective
um
as you probably are aware we operate
under the guise of the clean air act um
as opposed to the race divisions
federal regulations
and
the these type of facilities would be
treated just like any other
manufacturing facility that coming into
the state we would address
meet with them take a look at the
specific process as mike mentioned
and make a determination
the bill that you have in front of you
proposes
revisions to to rsa 149m which is a
solid waste statute
it would not have any impact on
rsa 125c and rsa 125i
which are the statutes that we operate
under
and we also have
state
authority for implementing the clean air
act on a federal basis
and so
i would like to ask todd for for a
moment there is a currently a dialogue
going on
regarding air regulations for these type
of facilities
epa
recently issued
a request for
information to be submitted to them
in in their consideration of revisions
to what's known as um the osweg
regulations other solid waste
incinerators
so
um but they're what they're doing is
they're looking at these type of
facilities and so i'd like to ask todd
if he could kind of just summarize
briefly what what epa's doing and what
the status of that is
i'll scoot out
todd moore i'm the air permitting
programs manager at des
relative to federal action
epa on the air side clean air act
has a section that specifically targets
solid waste incinerators
for many years
both the industry and epa and us
implementing these rules have struggled
with where does pyrolysis gasification
where do those types of facilities fit
in
epa recognizing
well i think what they said is they
recognize it's not clear
in the existing structure and also
they've had a number of inquiries um
recently about people wanting to use
these types of facilities so what
they've done is they issued a rule
they they requested officially
information so they opened a public
comment period i believe that
chemistry council submitted comments
similar to what their um you know some
of the things that they've said here
today is it fair to say though that this
uh industrial process is in its early
days so to speak and so therefore
they're
they're trying to gather more
information in terms of
the emissions so that they can issue the
specific guidelines that
that the public would require
i'm not as familiar with the actual if
you're saying that if the industry
itself is still in its infancy i'm not
sure i think these types of
chemical processes are probably in use
in various manufacturing facilities
but maybe how they're being used but
again it's been
a number of years now that people have
struggled to figure out where they fit
into incinerator regulations and i
you know i don't want to speak for epa
but those incinerator regulations were
primarily developed looking at your
classic incinerators uh recognizing
these are not those
one more
yep one more and then i'll go to
representative
we just heard anecdotally from the
gentleman speaking before about uh smoke
tac testing at some of these facilities
in ohio i believe is that your
understanding on the the
manufacturing regulations that that
would happen in new hampshire that would
that the des would go in and test the
smoke tax smokestack at these facilities
um
there's no
separate set of manufacturing
regulations per se
if somebody were to propose a facility
in new hampshire
we would need specific details on size
type what are they doing what materials
are they using we would take that
information determine whether
or not any of the existing rules apply
i don't know i'm not familiar with the
ohio facility they may because of the
current regulate regulatory structure be
subject to federal incinerated
regulations that that prompted the
testing i'm not really sure
yeah thank you thank you representative
i'd like to if i could just clarify
again we would look at this process as
we would look at any company coming into
new hampshire for
uh within with a new manufacturing
process we would meet with them as todd
said we would
evaluate they would provide us with
specific detailed diagrams and drawings
and so on as to
what the process is what the inputs are
what the outputs are
and we would compare that against our
existing state regulations and any
federal regulations to determine what is
applicable and from there we would issue
if necessary if it was applicable we
would issue a permit
pursuant to a stat to rsa 125c or 125i
which is a toxic
regulation
and that permit
may or may not incorporate
um
testing requirements and stack testing
so on depending on on what we
what we determine so everything would be
very process specific and
any
definition of paralysis or gasification
or anything
really would be sort of irrelevant from
our perspective it's just
what's going in
what's coming out
what's being emitted
and is it regulated under either rsa
125c or 125i
um
and uh
if there were any
uh determination of of applicability of
some clean air act uh requirement that's
above and beyond those
thank you representative and then
representative bixby
thank you madam chair and thank you
gentlemen for taking my question i have
a couple
um
would this
based on
i guess my question is is because you're
solid waste
and the des but you said it it doesn't
matter if it's a manufacturing facility
or
anything the rsa does not change is that
correct that's that's because the year
statutes are applicable no matter what
the regulatory status is under under a
different program okay follow up
um
if if um
do you know of
any of these other plants in other
states how they're doing the air quality
and how it would affect our statutes in
this state and what manpower would take
to do testing
we
we really have not looked at this
too carefully because we we haven't been
approached with a a facility there there
is one facility that's doing some
processing up in uh groveton
that approached us um
and
we made a determination that uh
based on the information they provided
us that that was a closed loop facility
that there were no air emissions
and that
those
uh that that facility
they had originally proposed that one of
the products that they would come from
that would be used as a fuel for a
generator
on site but they subsequently came to us
and said no the generator will only be
fueled with diesel fuel
and so we issued a permit for that
facility so but as to what's happened in
in other
uh other states and so on we we have not
been approached with a specific facility
that we would want to evaluate but
certainly if that were the case we would
look to
similar facilities in other states and
see what determinations had been made
but again it would be specific to the
process and the facility
that's being proposed
follow up
thank you madam chair yeah my i guess um
i understand uh that the groveton is a
closed loop facility but they're talking
and i don't know if the facility that
would be proposed in new hampshire
would have smoke stacks but apparently
um that has been mentioned
and obviously
there is an emission through smoke
stacks so how would des handle that
same as we would handle any other
smokestack industry in the state we
would they would again come to us we'd
evaluate the process
we'd look at all the inputs and outputs
and determine
our statutes are very clear as to
if there are certain levels of
contaminants
that could be emitted
they they would be
they would be required to be controlled
and they would be they would be required
to have process controls
um and that would all be incorporated
into a permit that we would issue and
that would be subject to public
input we don't we'd hold a hearing
receive input on that permit
and ultimately issue a issue a permit
that required
perhaps controls
and
also
could require a schedule of air testing
stack testing um but again it would be
no different
than how we would approach any other
manufacturing facility in the state we
have hundreds of facilities here in the
state that have permits and do
you know do routine stack testing we go
out we observe those stack tests we
review their records and conduct
inspections and so on and make sure that
they're operating in accordance with
their permit
representative bixby yes thank you um
so
it sounds like there there's a range of
um stack emissions that are clearly uh
covered by the
uh clean air act and by our state
statutes
are there potential emissions that
are not covered by that
are there compounds that may not be
specifically identified that could
conceivably be coming out of a stack
um
the clean air act is very clear it has a
list of hundreds of we're known as
hazardous air pollutants haps
we have a regulation known as enva 1400
uh which is pursuant to rsa 125i the
toxic statute
that has again i believe todd 700 some
compounds on it
that we would we would require a
determination to be made if they're
emitting any of those compounds
i suspect that you may be
alluding or concerned about pfas um uh
fast dioxin
and and
all of those are all of those are
covered and i just want to with regards
to pfas
back in 2016 with the
determination of the air emissions
problem in southern new hampshire
related to a manufacturing facility in
merrimack there
well the legislature passed a new
statute
that amended rsa 125 c that gave us very
specific authority with regards to
certain pfas compounds
and and
so
that we would also measure
and and determine whether
that law that statute applied
um to ensure that that uh
pfas compounds were addressed but the
whole suite of of other compounds would
be would be looked at that's you know
hundreds of vpa haps and our 700 under
our toxics laws
um and so
we'd make a determination that in that
right relative to those yeah i i
i guess one of my concerns is that um
there are
a certain number of identified p-pass
compounds and there are others that are
not yet
categorized uh and
uh there are you know
potentially other compounds that we may
not i mean at one at some point we
didn't realize that pfas was an issue
and now we do and i'm wondering about
those other potential compounds that we
don't recognize as an issue at the
moment but in fact may be
so again uh
uh the revisions to rsa 125c in 2016
were intended to address not only
those
pfast compounds that we know
but also
what are we referred to as sort of an
emerging
emerging contaminants and
again as you mentioned there are
hundreds of pfas
compounds
and as the science emerges on those and
really relatively few of those compounds
pose an air inhalation risk
the changes to 125c that we made in 2016
and working with the legislature on
were
relative to how those compounds were
emitted into the air
then landed on the ground then got into
groundwater because that is a much more
prevalent and much more
uh
significant route of exposure
drinking water that contains those
compounds is vastly different than
inhaling air
that contains them in terms in terms of
the risks for those compounds
so the way that statute reads is
if
in our waste and water divisions if we
make a determination that some one of
those pfas compounds
is regulated from a water standpoint
then
the way the new revision to 125c works
is if that compound is emitted into the
air
we would then model and test to
determine does it have the potential to
contaminate the water
if it did then we would limit it
in such a way so that there would be no
impact to
to surrounding water bodies
the science of inhalation risk with
regards to these compounds
is
developing
there is currently a bill that was just
heard today i believe it was heard here
in the house
it was a house bill
1546 i believe
related to
air emissions of perfluorochemicals and
pfas compounds
and it was just
voted in the senate
ought to pass
voted in the senate committee today and
that
bill
would require requires us to
annually look at all of the
scientific literature related to air
inhalation risk of pfast compounds
and
do a report to the legislature and
report out whether we intend to regulate
one of those compounds
on the basis of air so we we actually
look at pfas on two fronts we look at it
for its potential to contaminate water
which is
a much more well established and
significant exposure route
and its potential for air emissions the
same as we would do with any of the
other hundreds of compounds that are on
on our list
and so so this build now requires us
assuming that it's signed by the
governor would require us to annually
look at
at
all the literature related to pfas
inhalation and make a determination if
we needed to add them to our list
thank you
are there any other questions for the
department
uh representative kaplan i have a
general question i don't know if any
gentleman can answer it's about the
greenhouse gas
issue and
we heard that
this process would lower greenhouse
gases compared i believe to our current
recycling
model
do you like do you does your department
do any calculations around the
greenhouse gas or the carbon uh
footprint of this process compared to
uh say actually trying to reduce the
amount of plastic that we use we we do
in general but i would i would defer to
the gentleman from acc we haven't looked
at this issue specifically but i uh he
did indicate that they had done some
um
[Music]
that they had done some studies uh which
it's a very complicated subject because
you have to look at the full process
heat that's being used to the
energy that's being used to heat the
process
what happens to the
uh to the ultimate products and so on um
but but i i would assume that if
you know that there's there may be
studies out there that show that the
overall um
uh use of of uh or emissions of
greenhouse gases
um
uh i i wouldn't doubt that it could be
potentially be local we haven't done any
specific
dive into this
representative
let me go to representative stapleton
please
thank you
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um i heard we heard testimony previously
that the department
is comfortable with the language in this
bill
so my question is
have you spent a great deal of time
investigating the
various other states
that have implemented legislation
similarly
and are there differences that you
picked out to
apply for our new hampshire application
thank you we we have not studied the
other states in detail um i know that on
the air side todd and others in the air
division have looked at this ongoing
topic for its last several years with
epa but as far as other states that have
implemented this or the other states
that have facilities
no we've not investigated that
our support for this bill really lies in
the the idea that um
we believe that you know we hear from
our stakeholders we hear from the
legislature
that there is a very strong desire to
reduce the amount of materials that go
into landfills or to incinerators for
disposal
and to
recycle much more particularly plastics
than we currently do and we see this as
an opportunity whether a facility would
be cited here in new hampshire or
elsewhere in the region we see advanced
recycling as a potential for
significantly increasing that diversion
rate of plastics
and as we viewed it the acc and the
sponsors came to us early in the fall
we identified with their original bill
about five or six concerns
they addressed all of those concerns
except for one when we got to the first
hearing in the senate
and it became evident from my testimony
in the senate that we still had not
reconciled that one issue that issue was
surrounding
again is a very practical consideration
for me because as a director of the
waste division and solid waste is part
of my the purview of my division we do
occasionally get people managing solid
waste or storing it in a way that
creates some kind of at the very least a
nuisance so you know if you've got
plastics they may have food residues or
other organics associated with them um
that um that can attract bugs or rats or
seagulls or you name your favorite pests
and if they're not managed properly
those things can create a nuisance or a
public health or environmental threat
and my concern with the original version
of the bill was that if we if we if the
bill were to pass and those
plastics that were being stored at an
advanced recycling facility were not
subject to solid waste law
we would not have authority we often
have a health officer call us and say
hey this guy's storing waste in a way
that's creating a rat problem or
whatever
and
normally we can use our authority under
the solid waste statute to address that
and i was concerned that with the
original draft of the bill we wouldn't
have that authority and i articulated
that to the committee and then we worked
back with the acc and the bill sponsors
and eventually arrived at an amendment
that's contained in the current amended
version of the bill
that basically says with respect to
storage of these materials at the
facility prior to them entering the
recycling you know the the processing
process
we still retain our authority to enter
and inspect the facility to determine
whether that storage is creating any
kind of a nuisance or environmental
health threat um and then to use our
authority under 149 m to address that if
we find such a threat so
with that provision entered into it the
agency
no longer had opposition to the bill and
we and we elected to support the bill
so that's the one maybe more than you
wanted but that's the story of the bill
for des
representative bixby and then i have a
question myself yeah i have a um a
couple of related questions which uh we
weren't able to get answered last week
by anyone who was here so um
why does the current classification of
recycling as solid waste create an
impediment for advanced recycling
well
that's a good question i i you know one
one of those i'll be very candid with
you one of the discussions we had when
we first started talking with acc and
the bill sponsor
about this was
what is the problem and my i i don't
know i i think you'd have to ask them i
mean i think it it would still be
possible to cite and operate
successfully an advanced recycling
facility in new hampshire under the
current regulatory scheme
there may be aspects of that scheme that
are make it uncomfortable maybe it's a
stigma i don't know
the way that the rules work right now
any products that might be manufactured
from so let's say that an advanced
recycling facility is cited here under
the current regulatory scheme without
this bill passing
and um they take in
i don't know let's just sure it's always
teachers to talk about actual examples
they say they take in agricultural
plastics which is really an area where
we want to see some benefit because most
of that now goes to disposal in
landfills which is a shame it's a lot of
resource going to waste
and let's say they take in a lot of that
material and they they break it down
into its monomers and they make a new
plastic
and for sale maybe it's i don't i don't
know what they can do this maybe they
make a new agricultural plastic that's
gonna go right back to the same use
under the current rules that would be
considered what's called a certified
waste dry product they would have to get
a certification from the agency that
that you know basically they would have
to make sure that it met that that that
definition
um we looked at this and we don't think
that actually adds any particular
protections or value
and so that's why we were comfortable
saying okay if this bill were to pass
and you operated a facility like that
you wouldn't have to get that
certification you could just make your
product and and market it
um and that may be again that's
conjecture on my part because i'm not
trying to cite an advanced recycling
facility but um that may be that that
kind of requirement is unattractive to
the folks who are trying to operate
these facilities so i think that
question is probably better directed to
to acc than it is to me you actually
that was a very helpful answer um
and uh
the so another question i have is and
uh would classifying
the plastic going in as feedstock as
not solid waste
have
a
would that impact the way that we count
our plastic diversion goals in the solid
waste plan
uh yeah that that's a great question and
i think the answer is both yes and no
depending on the circumstances so if you
talk about
and again just listening to the
conversation with the other witnesses
let's say that we get to a point where
um
uh typical waste that you and i generate
a you know a granola bar wrapper or a or
a beef jerky wrapper or something like
that which we normally throw in the
trash right now and it goes to a
landfill um if that's
in in a new environment with an advanced
recycling facility in the region became
those kinds of plastic
an additional group of plastics became
recyclable and we got to a point where
you could put those in addition to your
ones and twos you could put threes fours
and fives in your recycling bin
and that went to a murph a materials
recovery facility to be separated and
then eventually that fraction found its
way to an advanced recycling facility
then yes it would be counted because
the way that we collect data we would
know that um
uh the
transfer stations that collected that or
the or the haulers that collected that
would report that they sent x tons to
that materials recovery facility and if
and and so basically we would know that
that essentially was was diverted from
disposal that's where you get to a yes
where you might get to a no is let's say
there's a farmer it's the things that we
don't know about right let's say there's
a farmer in the upper valley
who generates
three roll-offs every spring or every
fall whatever of of agricultural
plastics that he used to to store his
hay bales or his hay you know
um
then he might just ship those if if
there were a facility like this he might
ship those roll offs of plastic directly
there
we don't really have any way of
collecting that information we don't
he's not uh he's not a solid waste
facility he's going directly to an
advanced recycling facility um we
wouldn't necessarily know that so i
think they're
you know
but but i would hasten to add that we
don't know that now either
so if there is a farmer who has found an
outlet for his agricultural plastic
we don't hear about it we don't know
about it so we may want to con consider
putting something into the bill that
would
um
make that would help us count that sort
of thing
to make sure that make sure that
plastics that end up at these facilities
do in fact get uh counted towards the
diversion goals
uh with respect there there may be a
legislative way to do that i'm not sure
trying to accomplish it with this bill i
i i think that would take some
consideration to try to figure that that
is not there's perhaps a more complex
question than it sounds like okay thank
you
uh
yep i'll i'll get to you it's may i ask
a question right yep
uh could i just follow up
on that lasting question and answer just
just a quick i just wanted to point out
that from based on what i heard today
that not only are there benefits on the
front end of diverting
plastics and so on
but
on the back end
if i what i heard is correct that there
would be a usable product that is made
that would replace
potentially new product
um you know for instance they would they
would make
some type of of plastic feedstock
that would go to go to a plastics
facility and would replace the need for
new
petroleum-based plastic feedstocks
so
i think i think there's there's two and
two wins of this just
that ought to be
taken into consideration so
but as as you um
as you probably are aware this is a
fairly complicated
process and there is a lot of regulatory
there are a lot of regulatory
implications there are a lot there are
certain number of safety implications
there it's
there is there are aspects of it are
very attractive but we don't want to do
um a partial job of
oversight on it
thank you so i have i have two questions
and one may be directed to you and one
may be to the acc so let's start with
the one
let me ask them both to you and if you
feel like one is germane to you then
that's fine
um
going back to your conversation about
how items are stored at the facility and
in the event that they are stored in the
open air
and
they are open to the elements they're
exposed to the sun degree plastic
degradation is the thing water runoff
those types of things
what type of mechanism within the bill
do you have to ensure
that there isn't going to be runoff or
degraded plastic sitting out in the open
somewhere
that could potentially pose a threat to
the environment
i think that the the the provision of
the bill that was amended it does give
us the authority to enter inspect and if
we identify either a nuisance or an
environmental threat we can act to
address that
so i think that it probably makes it
equivalent to
the authority we have now to address
that question
at a at one of these facilities under
the current um
of the current uh regulatory scheme
so i guess and and to follow up if i may
would you have
more or less of a concern with items
that are stored outdoor versus indoor
and an enclosed unit
well certainly indoor is always is
almost unless it's a hazardous material
that is unsafe to store indoors indoors
almost always better for storing
materials because you eliminate
all the weather issues and the and run
you know rain and precipitation and all
that
thank you
and i guess then the other question that
i do have is that uh you had mentioned
that there was a change in scope in in
an applicant i believe that had desired
to go from one industry to another
does that require them to start the
process over or amend their scope or how
does that work
no no our
our permitting process what
occurs is as i mentioned the facility
would sit down with us they would
provide all of the information they
would fill out an application for a
permit if we determined that they were
subjected to that required to those
requirements
in this case the facility
indicated to us initially that they
planned to take the product that they
were producing the liquid product they
were producing and use that as a fuel
for the generator
during the permitting process before we
ultimately issued the final we made a
determination that the process itself
was not subject to permitting that it
was closed loop and
and but
then
uh you know generators uh
emergency generators or general electric
generators at facilities are subject to
our regulations they combust fuel and
there's and there's air emissions with
those so if they're of a certain size
they're subject to our regulations
we the original application information
or the original discussions as i
understand it
were that they intended to use that fuel
they subsequently came to us and amended
that and said no
we intend to just use diesel fuel which
radically simplified the
process for for issuing a permit for the
generator and but no permit was
necessary for the process
great thank you for clarifying
representative stapleton thank you so
much for your patience
yeah thank you for um
thank you for my take my question um
that was an interesting example that you
made with the farmer with a volume of
roll-off plastic and
he packs it into a truck at the end of
the year and then sends it to a plant
for re
cycling or reprocessing i mean that's a
clean example
uh there would be no reason for a
landfill
permit regarding that because it's a
direct from
a user to a processor
i was at the landfill transfer station
in claremont not long ago and
wondered all of these plastics that come
from food containers
all different types
and i asked the transfer
person
you know what happens to these things
and he pointed out that these pla
manufacturers are putting plastic codes
type of plastic codes
on these various containers
so if you have
a consolidator or aggregator they can
separate these things out and into
different categories of plastics and
make a bulk volume
that
this industry could buy for processing
in which case it never goes into the
landfill
that's what we're looking at here so why
would we give a landfill permit
to a a material that's never going to go
into the landfill that that's the way i
see it and that's the question
why should we have to
you know run run through landfill
permits and considerations if it's only
going to go to processing like scrap
metals
for instance
yes and i agree with your analysis sorry
i do want to clarify just just so that i
i haven't i don't i hope i haven't
confused anybody
under the current regulatory scheme a
facility that would do this kind of
advanced recycling would not actually be
required to get a permit they would be
what's called a permit exempt
solid waste processing facility so they
really have just a basic core
set of requirements that would apply to
them much less than what is applied to
to a even a transfer station or or a
landfill or any other type of facility
um
but uh but i understand yeah your point
i think is exactly right if more of you
know
you're never as dumb as you are at home
um nobody thinks i know anything there
so when i tell them you can't put threes
fours and fives and sixes in recycling
they think i'm wrong and they say you
don't know anything about recycling so
communities have struggled for years
to try to get people to put the things
into their single stream recycling or or
separated only the things that they
actually recycle in that community and i
live in concord and in concord we don't
recycle threes fours fives and sixes
they just they just don't have an outlet
for it they want the ones and twos
so the hope would be if we get to a
future state where in the region of the
country we have a variety of these kind
of facilities that can handle these
other
codes of plastics more of the plastics
will be diverted from the disposal the
waste stream that is traditionally now
going to disposal
yeah thank you so it's a growth
potential or a growth industry with a
lot of potential to alleviate this
problem we would hope yes thank you
thank you i do have another question and
being conscientious of the time
um uh i did have one for the acc so i
think unless there's other questions for
the department
great okay thank you
thank you
thank you um so
i i did have another question you
earlier in your testimony had testified
to there being less suitable plastics
for processing such as maybe
multi-layered chip bags or anything of
those types of sorts right now that
we're talking about
um
at the moment but
i guess what i i
to director wimsat's point we are well
aware in this committee that there are
plastics that are suitable for recycling
and some that are not and it even sounds
to me that there is some debate among
your own industry or or that those that
you represent
whether or not you can
potentially use those for pyrolysis so
could you elaborate about where you are
right now with those specific
types of plastic that are multi-layered
that type of thing
no the technologies can take
multi-layered plastics um
i guess i think the key thing is there's
there's so advanced recycling is not
sort of one monolithic um
it's not one sort of monolithic thing
right there are different inputs
um depending upon the plastics that
oftentimes are dependent upon the
technology used so there's four
technologies that are kind of defined in
the bill uh
uh gasification sovolysis and
depolymerization
and then depending upon the input the
process used there might be a different
output
so for example
polystyrene which folks know is
sometimes styrofoam although that's a
misnomer for it's actually a insulation
it's not what you think of as your
dunkin donuts coffee cup or you know
your foam coolers
through the pyrolysis process if you
just have polystyrene you can actually
make essentially a styrene monomer
um that goes right back in the
production of polystyrene and so it
could go back into uh you know your solo
cup which is you know you think of that
as a drink cup or into
um you know a
a plastic plate or something or a bowl
so it's it's kind of dependent upon the
technology used the inputs and the
process and then of course the customer
so we have companies like america
styrenics that has committed to a goal
of 25
of all the food service plastics that
they produce
are made from recycled content um so
again they're a sort of a polystyrene
producer so
i don't know if that answers your
question but
you know i mentioned uh eastman taking
carpet carpet is very difficult to
recycle
mechanically but they're taking it
they're taking it out of places like
california
and michigan and others and can take
that and turn it back into you know
again it's sort of basic molecules and
then use it to rebuild into different
types of products again so it'll it all
depends but pyrolysis um for the most
part is going to take polyethylene so
think your
um
i think your you know
you know your your your milk jugs your
detergent bottles so those have good
markets right now so they're not likely
but we're often your film plastics so
the film that's around toilet paper and
paper towels um you know again snack
pouches drink pouches your
frozen pea bags things like that
polypropylene which you often times find
sometimes in like squeeze bottles you
find it in uh sometimes in like clam
shells that have like muffins and things
in them you find them in deli containers
and tubs and lids ice cream sometimes is
packed in polypropylene and then also
polystyrene which again you see in
different applications as well i named a
few
representative bixby sure
yes thank you um
so
um
in the discussion i the the term came up
that i was kind of looking for and i
didn't uh i hadn't like remembered it
before but um
the uh closed-loop pro a closed-loop
process which is essentially a process
where you don't have
uh outputs other than you don't have
waste output so basically you have your
input and then
everything uh
yeah and then you have con essentially
controlled output of any of everything
that that's coming out of it
would you are these advanced recycling
facilities closed loop facilities or are
there emissions and effluents that
uh are necessarily part of the process
yeah that's a good question
so i would say i i i don't really know
of any manufacturing process that is 100
closed loop unless it's
running 100 on solar energy
um
and also then producing zero byproduct
or waste um so if if
that's happening i'd you know show me
that
number one um so number two i i think i
mentioned sort of that right now um
these it's sort of an 80 10 10
proposition which is better than what
we're doing right now so your frozen pea
bag your
your your pouch of granola or beef jerky
or you know snack mix with peanuts and m
m's and things like that that stuff's
going to landfill so through these
technologies at least through pyrolysis
you'd get about 80 percent of that back
into a liquid feedstock that can be
turned into new plastics again you would
get about 10 percent of this char and as
i mentioned they're trying to get to
close loop because they want everything
they produce remember it's a business so
anything that they have to
isn't a product that they can sell as a
cost to them so they're are actively
looking for markets for what you can do
with this
chart i mentioned sort of carbon black
as one potentially as part of a cement
binder as well asphalt is kind of
another there's a lot of different sort
of testing going on but then there is a
10 percent of these non-condensable
gases um if you were co-located with a
chemical plant you could potentially use
those gases to actually become a
feedstock for new plastics and other
things again here in new hampshire
though that's probably
unlikely so it is used as a process
energy i think the key thing though is
is is you got to think of this in the
context of how much so a company called
good company out of eugene oregon did
some emissions modeling and there was a
good discussion about hazardous air
pollutants and um
criteria air pollutants right so number
one these facilities are well well well
below title five thresholds that's when
you have to go to the epa to get a um
a permit and then number two when you
look at the criteria air pollutants no
different than you know
a college or a hospital you know i mean
so when you look at the
you know
um energy needed at the university of
new hampshire in durham or keene state
college or you know
dartmouth hitchcock right because they
have a boiler to produce because they
need you know you need heat in the cold
new hampshire winters right you need
steam for showers and things like that
um the emissions from these facilities
are basically the same or lower than
colleges and universities
and we can provide that report as um
serve as a follow-up too
please please do so um so
um is there anything in the emission
emissions other than carbon dioxide and
um and and
water or is it um i i i i i'm and and
comparing that to a hospital or to a uh
or a particular college campus i'm
thinking about the
hoods in the chemistry department and
with the acetone and stuff being
volatilized that so there there are
there are emissions that you might not
necessarily be happy about
with that even in a university or at a
hospital uh so
um but uh
so
uh if it if the emission are there other
emissions besides uh
the um
besides just carbon dioxide and and
water coming out of the stack yes i mean
there's small amounts of things like you
know hydrogen oxide right nox
um that's a good example so again we can
provide that information to modeled
against hospitals universities other
manufacturing facilities
so
you're not going to have you're not
going to have zero uh emissions at sort
of any sort of manufacturing unless
they're 100 solar powered or wind
powered right now right and one
follow-up from representative bixby and
then representative
and
uh is there any effort to use co2
scrubbers to reduce the
greenhouse gas emissions
i mean
i think number one is
co2 generated is is very little
um
again because you're not going to have
you know especially in pyrolysis
technologies there's not oxygen atoms
going into the system number two the
carbon um you're going to take
you know you want to use those carbon
atoms as i mentioned because that
provides that bonds with the hydrogen to
form you know your liquid feedstock that
you're going to sell
when there is you know there's always
going to be look to sort of
improve the footprint because i think
that's a it's an important sort of
bigger societal question that you ask is
how we continually lower our carbon
footprint of everything we're doing
and the studies out there now are
showing that if you take
it you know there's the the one model
the linear model where you take oil or
natural gas out of the ground you make
plastics and then you take them and you
either land fill them or you
well you do do some recycling as well
some mechanical recycling but you either
land fill them
or you
combust them for energy through a waste
energy plant and then you have to go
back and drill for an additional
unit of oil or gas to then make into new
plastics again that's one model right
right versus model number two of what
we're suggesting which is use the
plastics
instead of landfilling them or
combusting them burning them
incinerating them
take them back turn them back into a
liquid feedstock again
and displace that additional unit of oil
or natural gas
the scenario b that i just laid out is
going to have a lower greenhouse gas
footprint so this is helping us get to
lower greenhouse gas is it zero
greenhouse gases no but it's not it's
going to be lower okay i i guess
i'm more concerned about if you're using
natural gas or um
or the the pyro the the gas fraction of
the uh from the pyrolysis
then
that is you know that is potential
carbon dioxide and i it sounds like you
that that still would be an effluent or
a an emission an emittant after
in this process so i think we're going
to continue to see a greening of the
grid which is important as well which
will further reduce the footprint of
these technologies um
uh company agilex based up in the
pacific northwest up in uh portland
oregon they you know draw
renewable energy off the grid because
they have a a lot of hydro there so as
new hampshire let's say greens its grid
i think in the northeast you're very
reliant of course on natural gas up here
um
you know there's potential there's
there's really good greening potential
um and and that kind of reminds me is
closeup partners which is a new
york-based investment firm did a whole
very long if you're interested in
reading 100 plus pages on these
technologies and they cover sort of
different types of technologies and
inputs did a report that they released
in november and they looked at the
emissions and they talk about this right
number one the lower ghg
impact and the potential to get even
lower with the greening of the grid okay
would you be able to uh send us a
reference to that closing we'll send it
all okay great thank you representative
representative stapleton thank you
we hear a lot about
lightweight and strong carbon fiber
bicycle frames paddles canoes and
various other things that is popular now
in athletics
to what extent if any
is char
carbon a component of these things or is
it completely unrelated
you know that's a good question i mean i
think
i thought you were going a little bit
different with that story because i
think one of the things from the closed
loop report um
or in your question one of the things
for the close group reported it does
talk about the potential textiles is
another great example of material that
we really don't have solutions for right
now and there's a real opportunity
because you know again and i mentioned
sort of eastman and the work that
they're doing around carpet to use
advanced recycling technologies to
recycle those materials um but you make
a good point is as these companies again
continue to commercialize
the
the interest in sort of having a lower
and lower environmental impact and that
includes any emissions that includes any
greenhouse gas emissions associated it
includes being able to take a by-product
and turn it into a product that could go
into something like you were mentioning
um you know using the carbon that's an
interesting opportunity so i think again
the the goal here you know these are
for-profit companies
so
they are incented you know to stay in
business
to produce something that can be sold as
a product right that's the i think
really the key thing here
follow-up follow-up representative
stapleton yeah the analogy that i can
think of going back to the old days in
coal mining um you know around coal
mining towns like scranton the comb
piles all over the place
they're non-existent anymore because as
technology developed they found a use
for these to making briquettes or uh
fuel uh
liquid fuels or liquid mixtures a coal
slurry
um and some even in chemical process and
uh virtually used up all of what was a
waste for some 50 or 60 years
thank you
yeah can i just build on that i think
that's a really important point is
i think we also have to remember that
technology and innovation continues to
improve
so there's sort of where we are now
which is actually a pretty good place
but we're going to continue to get
better um an analogy i like to use is
you know here's why my iphone is a
little cracked but
but
i remember when i first moved to
washington um
and everybody had these blackberry
things and i was like oh that's pretty
cool so you can be away from your
desktop computer because no one not many
people had laptops and you can
you can actually send and receive emails
away from your your desk uh which is
pretty cool at the time and and only
certain people had them um
and
and if you looked at them you know it
was kind of a black and white screen you
know it actually doubled as a phone but
no one really used the phone because it
wasn't that good and you think where we
are you know when the iphone came out a
few years later and now where we are
with our personal devices there's more
technology in this than there is in the
computers that sent um our astronauts to
the moon so
as i talk about greening potential and
innovation that continues right so i
think that's an important point is
you know
this these technologies have in this
this
business has has changed in just the
last couple years and will continue to
change and get more efficient and better
um
and you know and and we've kind of
talked about some of the plastics that
um you know they don't take right now
but there's potential for taking you
know additional types of plastics in the
future as we continue there's a lot of
university research i mean there's an
opportunity potentially for
if
you know if if you had a technology here
in new hampshire for students from the
university of new hampshire right to be
able to work with these technologies get
hands-on experience right and how we do
a better job managing our resources
after we've used them
yep
thank you representative bixby and then
yeah so uh one issue that has uh been uh
been
sort of on our radar for the last few
years in the legislature is
uh the
is the biomass industry in um in new
hampshire so we have a fairly active
timber industry and they um harvest a
fair number of high grade high grade
logs and when you once you mill those
logs there's a lot of bark there's a lot
of other biomass that is not
particularly useful for
them for
as wood itself and
uh for a long time we had uh you know
several biomass
energy plants which were not vastly
efficient at least i think we're down to
maybe one at this point
and they needed to have sort of a
special
category for their
um
for counting their uh
the the renewable renewable energy
credits for the energy they produced in
order to help their balance sheets
uh
it looks like uh with the way
regulations are going
uh now there's going to be less and less
of an outlet for that biomass
uh on in the energy sector and i was
reading about um pyrolysis and it sounds
like biomass can uh can be incorporated
along with plastics into pyrolysis and
that will drive their reaction more
towards aromatics rather than alkanes
as that something that your
that your council is looking at as a
potential
uh
resource in new hampshire
i i think
i mean most of the companies you know
getting started try to you know looking
at the low-hanging fruit right which is
like your polyethylene and polypropylene
uh plastics but i think you hit on
something very important right is that i
think biomass is going to be
increasingly
a feedstock
as the industry looks to get you know
the industry as a whole
looks to get um
you know lower its carbon footprint it's
going to continue to look to
both recycled products but also
feedstocks made from bio uh the
mcdonald's drink cup is a great example
of sort of a you know one of these um i
mentioned the uh
the the ellen macarthur foundation and
the 400 companies that have committed to
you know higher levels of recycled
content there's also sort of the
spin-off of that is called the u.s
plastics pact and about a hundred
companies have made commitments to use
thirty percent recycled content in their
packaging and other products but
in that part of that thirty percent is
less talked about it's thirty percent
either recycled plastics or from
sustainably sourced biomass
feedstock so i think that's
i would say it's less mature
than where we are now on the you know on
sort of using pyrolysis for recycling
plastics but it's definitely coming and
you're right i mean there are companies
that are looking at sort of how you
incorporate biomass it's going to change
the molecular structure and then you
have different types of outputs that you
can produce
thank you without seeing any further
questions i'd actually like to have um
i believe there's a gentleman here from
the clf that would like to come forward
and i just want to be honest with
everyone as to where we're at right now
i'd like to give you
five minutes to come up and
speak about the issues and concerns you
may have but then we are going to
continue this conversation next week
at 1pm on tuesday is that correct yep
thank you
so um with that i will have you and
thanks again for the questions and we'll
make sure that we provide um
all the reports and other studies that i
cited as well like closed loop and good
company on admissions and other things
okay thank you thank you
thank you
my colleague heidi tremarco was the one
who was at the public hearing i
apologize for not being able to attend
but clf is very interested in this bill
and we have a lot of significant
concerns
the first point i'd like to make is that
they're not really talking about a
manufacturing process in terms of
recycling if you think of recycling you
think of taking a plastic water bottle
and turning it into a plastic water
bottle correct
so what they're essentially doing with
these advanced recycling facilities is
they're creating a high-tech murph they
are taking plastics and creating it into
a feedstock that feedstock the liquid
uh generated that they talked about can
either be done for two things you can
burn it which is from our understanding
what is mostly happening to this
feedstock it is not being used in a
circular fashion to displace oil and gas
used for new plastic production it is
just being burned it is incineration
with extra steps
importantly it's very hard to track
exactly where this material is going
because once you exempt it from solid
waste regulations
you can't keep track of how much plastic
is going into this facility how much
plastic is then being sent to a facility
to either be used to make new plastic or
to be burned
so i think it's a little disingenuous to
refer to this as manufacturing you're
essentially doing the same thing murph
is doing which is taking a waste product
and murph's it's you know the single
stream the dual stream whichever have
you
and then sending it to somewhere where
it's manufacturing a new material this
is essentially the same thing it is a
waste process it should be regulated
that way
i would also note that they talked about
the bills in rhode island connecticut
new york
all of those bills have failed those
states have looked at this and decided
that this is not the direction they want
to go in because they have significant
concerns about whether this is actually
true recycling they want to make sure if
these facilities are built that they are
actually reporting where the waste is
coming from where it is going
new york recently had an epr bill that
had an advanced recycling provision they
tanked the whole bill because they were
so concerned about including that
definition in the process of recycling
that's the first point i wanted to make
they're essentially talking about a
material recovery facility not a
manufacturing process that the plants
that would take this liquid fuel and use
it to create new plastics that's
certainly manufacturing that wouldn't be
governed by the solid waste rules
additionally i took issue with the
statement that it is better for public
health to exempt
these types of facilities from the solid
waste regulations i wasn't exactly sure
of the train of thought there
there are significant public health
concerns with these facilities and when
they're regulated as a waste facility
they have to look at things like the
public benefit determination whether
there is going to be spills of the
material they're dealing with what is
the process of fires and you can
calculate how much is in state versus
out of state which i know is something
new hampshire is very interested in how
much of the plastic will actually be
generated in new hampshire for this type
of advanced recycling
it's important to note that new
hampshire is i believe the last state in
new england where they have tried to
push one of these bills they being the
american chemistry council they have
pushed similar bills identical bills
really in rhode island for the past
three years which have been continuously
struck down
i'd also like to point out that the
agriliks facility that was described is
a perfect example of how this is really
a murph so that
uses an advanced recycling process
called paralysis
to break down styrene or polystyrene
into styrene it has been found that most
of the styrene that they're producing
which again styrene is very toxic
is being sent to six different states
across the country primarily for burning
it is essentially a fancy way of
incinerating it it's processed in oregon
broken down into the monomer styrene
sent to colorado nebraska ohio and
missouri
as well as louisiana to be burned it is
not actually being recycled there's no
reporting that is required if you pass
this type of bill here in new hampshire
to actually track the material
i'd also like to point that a lot of the
questions talked about it depends
advanced recycling is a catch-all term
you're talking about paralysis
solvolysis gasification
there are reasons we have specific
regulations for landfills for composting
for recycling for the different types of
waste management practices that happen
in new hampshire that is because they're
different ways of dealing with solid
waste
des is responsible for figuring out what
kind of bucket something falls into and
then crafting regulations that are
specific to how we manage that type of
waste whether you are dealing with the
landfill and you have to make sure that
there's not going to be leaks
this is a new technology there are
significant concerns if you deregulate
it now
as this industry moves into maturation
you're not going to be able to go back
and regulate them you can't look at
what's going wrong and say okay
how can we look at this from a solid
waste perspective and pass regulations
particular to paralysis
or what is the difference between
paralysis and solace should there be
specific regulations that govern this
type of process you'd essentially be
restricting it just to the air permits
and additionally i'd like to point out
that yesterday there was actually a
report
that in georgia one of the states that
have deregulated this
still was not able to get one of these
facilities off the ground because
they're really just not economically
viable when you think about the process
you're taking plastics trying to break
it down into a monomer to create new
plastics you're competing against the
price of oil and natural gas which is
significantly low even with the inflated
numbers that we're seeing right now it
is
dirt cheaper to use that than to
actually go through this technological
process to create that feedstock which
is why most of this stuff is just being
burned
so in georgia
even though they deregulated it the
facility they were talking about it's a
bright mark facility it was going to be
about 600 million dollars they wanted
public funds to do it a condition of
getting those public funds was that they
needed to identify that the existing
facility that breitmark had in indiana
actually had a buyer for the material
that they were creating they weren't
specific whether that was go a buyer to
burn the material an incinerator or a
cement kiln or to use it to create a new
type of plastic the threshold was
significantly low just prove the
existing facility you have before you
build this new one in georgia
actually works and they couldn't do it
so the public funding was taken and the
facility's not moving forward i'd point
out that rsa
149 m-9 roman numeral 3 has a similar
provision
whenever dealing with a permit for solid
waste des is allowed to look into the
economic viability they can look at the
backers of a project and see how have
they fared in other jurisdictions do
they have the financial ability to move
forward with this project so that's one
of the key considerations that would be
removed if you deregulate this in one
fell swoop
and in terms of working with the local
governments which they said they try to
do when building these facilities i
would note you're removing the public
notice and comment process the public
hearings that are all associated with
waste facilities something that's
incredibly important as you've seen from
the ongoing issues with the granite
state landfill when you're building
waste facilities which in cf's view this
is a waste facility people have
significant concerns you're talking
about bringing a lot of waste to a
community
and in this instance there will be air
emissions
and people deserve to have a say in that
they deserve to be able to say is this
the right choice for us and go to the
des and work through the permitting
process
that public process will be taken out if
you deregulate this so it's not just
about the specific permitting factors
that are addressed for public health
environmental safety you're talking
about removing local control and the
ability to weigh in on whether this
facility should be developed
so those are the main points i had based
on kind of the thank you conversations i
heard i'm happy to answer any questions
and be back next tuesday all right
representative contra has a question and
then i'm going to go to representative
homeowner and then representative bixby
thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking
actually this question is for everyone
in the room
so my question is is because we've heard
contradictory information
regarding house bills that are now in
legislation
that either have passed have not been
passed or in study in each of those
states that were mentioned i would like
to know the bill numbers and the status
of those bills for next tuesday's
meeting if that's possible
thank you
representative
yes um thank you so much uh
one of the things i was actually kind of
curious about i'm i'm listening and i'm
trying to understand your major concerns
and one of the we heard from des prior
to you speaking
is one of your concerns that you feel
like you have unique information that
perhaps des doesn't have available to
them because i didn't get the impression
that they share your concerns
clf has been paying attention to
advanced recycling for quite some time
we've worked on the bills in rhode
island connecticut massachusetts to an
extent in new jersey and to an extent to
new york so we are significantly
concerned about the air emissions
related to these facilities and
exempting them full sail from solid
waste specifically again that reporting
requirement not being able to understand
where is the plastic coming from is that
plastic being turned into a fuel that is
then burned an incinerator in a cement
kiln or actually turned into a plastic
we see this as a green washing system
and we really are worried about how can
you actually heat these materials and
not have those byproducts released into
the air and there are many facilities
that have been taking this mostly the
ones that burn not the ones that turn it
into new plastics because there are very
few of them
that have serious clean air act
violations there's a facility in georgia
they just were fined i think 10 million
dollars under a title v clean air act
lawsuit they take styrene to
burn from advanced recycling facilities
so we have reports which i'm glad to
share with the committee and to des so
could i just quickly so just to confirm
to make sure i understand what you're
saying you're saying that based off the
information you have
you feel as if it may be
it yields a different result than what
des is coming up with
yes okay
representative bixby and then
uh representative kaplan and i think
then we're gonna have to call it for the
day and in the interest of time for
everybody and then we will continue this
next tuesday at 1pm
so um
i'm wondering if uh
if we were to mend this to uh put in a
stipulation that
uh
the in the definition of advanced
recycling saying that if the
uh that um
[Music]
using the products of this as fuel would
uh
void that classification as advanced
recycling uh would that um
would that address some of your issues
that would definitely address some of
our issues and i think that would be in
the interest of transparency to
understand where the liquid fuel that is
being produced is actually going
uh and
one of the things that we are
considering in in other venues in this
committee is uh advanced producer
responsibility which would in which
could include advanced resp
responsibility for single-use plastics
and
one of the questions that will come up
with that is well if the response the
re uh if the manufacturer
recaptures those uh those plastics
what do they do with them then
and
one possibility is
some sort of advanced recycling
what sorts of
further regulation would be necessary
for advanced recycling in order to make
it really workable
and this is something that you if you
want to come back with this next week
that's fine
um
i will note that there are two extended
producer responsibility for packaging
laws in the u.s one in maine and one in
oregon i worked very heavily on the one
in maine
we were very careful to make sure that
there was no advanced recycling
definition in that bill that the key
part of making sure that when you have
an extended producer responsibility for
packaging system designed for a specific
state is to make sure that recyclability
is actually being used not at a national
level where something is theoretically
recyclable and that's an important part
with this the agrocycle
rolex facility in oregon
is shipping that material very far that
is a lot of greenhouse gases to to just
burn the material so you want to make
sure that with epr for packaging the
definition of recycling refers to the
actual jurisdiction can something be
captured in new hampshire processed and
turned into a new product is there an
end market that is specific to the state
or the region and with advanced
recycling we don't see that as an actual
possibility
most of the facilities are going to be
in the south where they are not as
stringent regulations and that's
mostly where this material is going
thank you and the final question goes to
representative kaplan this is just to
clarify a point that uh representative
homolo was asking about
because we heard from the des that
they're comfortable uh that a facility
like this coming into the state under
the current manufacturing regulations
that they would be able to make the
determination as to what kind of permit
uh would be uh applicable based on the
reporting from the facility as to the
feed stocks as to the processes
what about that process
makes you come to
the conclusion or what about the
regulations in new hampshire makes you
come to the conclusion that
wouldn't really quite capture the real
picture
that it shouldn't be a permit exam
facility that it should be treated the
same way a material recovery facility
would be treated which is you need to
make sure how much inbound material is
actually going to the facility where is
that material going after that the
material is actually being managed in a
proper and environmentally safe manner
we are significantly concerned again
that what des may think now their
current interpretation is based on a lot
of theoretical
information there are not a lot of these
facilities that are actually working
there is not a lot of information on
these facilities because they have been
deregulated in 18 states
if you exempt this now you can't go back
you need to pass a new legislation
saying that now it's solid waste again
let's develop some site specific
or not site specific but industry
specific regulations so first and
foremost i feel it would qualify as a
murph second you'd be completely cutting
off any ability to regulate them which
is it's an innovative new technology and
we need to learn how to deal with this
and figure out regulations that are
applicable to it
so with that uh yes we
she's welcome to send that along to us
and if she emails that to the entire
committee to house environment and
agriculture we will all get it including
the members who are not on the
subcommittee work session so please send
that along and with that we will see
everybody again on the 19th at 1 p.m
this is continued until then
yes
i was trying to practice
who gets a sheet with the attend part
you